billionaires for years um but
he he's advocated for a lower a
competitive
corporate tax which means lower um
but he seems to be okay with taxing the
wealthy like him more um and that you
know he said in his letter today that
wealthy people should keep in mind that
if their tax dollars go
to better you know society and the
economy that they ultimately benefit as
well
and diamonds commons come in the wave of
corporations and ceos speaking out about
social justice issues we're seeing all
of these ceos speaking out about voting
rights restrictions in the state of
georgia for example
i'm curious are these comments from
diamond uh just
good pr because this is expected of ceos
right now or is this
genuine yeah so look um i think there
are multiple factors at play here first
of all
jamie dimon and jp morgan have a lot of
people
dedicated to you know staying in tune
with this stuff whether it be
people in like pr people or lobbyist
people in washington etc
um but at the same time i mean he's
always been
outspoken um and so yeah of course i
mean of course corporations can do more
we've seen
we've seen them uh step up a bit in the
past year but of course there's always
room to do more but at the same time
diamond seems to um you know he makes an
economic case for it
uh which i think is worth noting and
he's talked about running for president
before do you think that this had any
political ambition behind it
or was it again was it genuine yeah look
so there's there's been speculation um
every cycle uh and as these annual
letters have
which he's been doing these forever but
they've gotten longer and dedicating
more space
um but he's he's shut that down so
yeah fair enough bloomberg's hannah
levitt thank you so much for joining us
appreciate it
all right in minneapolis the trial of
derek chauvin did continue today
the jury heard from jody steiger a los
angeles police department sergeant and
use of force expert
steiger said that chauvin never took his
knee off george floyd's neck
from the time officers put him on the
ground until paramedics arrived
and you tell the jury at what point in
time in your opinion does the restraint
itself begin
based on my review of the body worn
video
the restraint started at
20 19 and 14 seconds
and when does the restraint period end
i believe it was 20 28 and 43 seconds
and sir what is the duration then of
that time period the restraint period
nine minutes and 29 seconds
steiger's testimony came a day after
chauvin's attorney eric nelson
sought to point out moments in the video
footage when he said
chauvin's knee did not appear to be on
floyd's neck
chauvin is charged with murder and
manslaughter in floyd's death
last may and in other news from around
the world
an iranian ship believed to be a base
for the paramilitary revolutionary guard
has been attacked in the red sea that's
according to the country's
local government local officials suspect
the attack was carried out by
israel the assault came as iran and
several world powers met in vienna to
try and resurrect the tattered nuclear
deal
some experts do say the ship which has
been anchored in the red sea for years
has provided arms and support to yemen's
houthi rebels
iran has previously described the vessel
as aiding in anti-piracy efforts
and in turkey a visit from two top
european officials is igniting
conversation over
gender equality tv images show only two
chairs were available when president
erdogan met with ursula vonderlein and
charles michelle
as michelle took the seat next to
erdogan vonderlein was left standing
and eventually took the seat of a second
rank official on a nearby couch
brussels had this to say about the
incident the president
should have been seated exactly in the
same manner
as the president of the european council
and the
and the turkish president
but as i said she decided to proceed
nevertheless
prioritizing substance over protocol
and rwandan president paul gagami is
praising a french report documenting
france's role in the 1994 genocide
he says the rwandan government
interpreted the report as
saying france knew that a genocide
against the tutsis
was being planned by their rwandis
allies but continued to support them
france says its report clears it of
complicity in the massacres
this week marks the anniversary of the
beginning of the genocide that left
nearly 1 million people dead for the
latest news from your part of the world
go to bloomberg.com click on the
addition drop down right next to the
bloomberg masthead and choose your
region
and staying in africa jihadis in
mozambique forced the french energy firm
total
to suspend work at its multi-billion
dollar liquefied natural gas project in
the country
next up quick takes mark daniel davies
explains the conflict's origin and what
it could mean for southern africa's
economic development
this 20 billion dollar natural gas
project in northern mozambique
is the single biggest private investment
in africa
the government here hopes to reap as
much as 100 billion dollars in revenue
over the next 25 years
that's more than six times the country's
annual gdp
but what's meant to be a gas bonanza for
one of the world's poorest
countries is developing alongside a
deadly insurgency
i'm mark davies for bloomberg quick take
here's what you need to know
[Applause]
[Music]
since 2017 more than 2 600 people have
died
and 700 000 displaced as violent attacks
spread in the cabo delgado province
in march dozens of people were killed in
a raid by islamist militants
just a few miles from the project site
french gas giant total in response
halted operations on its 20 billion
venture for a second time
in 2021
they have done horrific things they are
still doing so they had seen bodies
laying on the streets
thousands are making their way by foot
boat and road
some are being rescued by the un's
humanitarian air services
evidence suggests insurgents in
mozambique's north began as an islamist
sect in 2007. by the mid-2010s it had
shifted to armed jihadism
the group carrying out attacks in the
capitol god is known as al-shabab
al-shabab just means a day of in arab
there is no known leakage with the group
with the same name operating in somalia
the first attack happened in 2017 but
the group
activity in terms of radicalization can
be traced
five years before i think that much of
this
really has to do with smuggling
syndicates
that have been operating for decades for
generations in the area
this is a really rural marginalized area
and they
they therefore serve as a very fertile
ground for for recruitment
and the only source in a sense of
employment of opportunity
is through smuggling networks and
through
radicals that offer them some payment
and some money
and it seems like the smugglers are
partly attempting to
protect their smuggling routes and and
building on local frustrations about the
potential mass gas exploration that is
developing
are able to recruit locals
[Music]
mozambique's army has struggled to
contain the violence so
far it's brought in russian and south
african private military companies to
quell attacks
with very little success more recently
the state has started social programs
targeting vulnerable young people
this in hopes of addressing discontent
over a lack of jobs and opportunities
but for now the conflict continues
the results are very poor even with
these
assistance for private military company
this group manages to attack and occupy
five district headquarters so five towns
that is huge in less than a year
mozambique fought a civil war 16 year
civil war
and did not see such a situation of
attacking and occupying district towns
like what is happening here
the region and regional governments like
south africa have long been aware of the
emerging problem but the government in
maputo like most governments have said
guys this is a national problem uh we
will deal with this nationally
there's a lot that southern africa
the africa union and the international
community can do
but eventually um it's all dependent
upon the will
and the capacity of the government in
maputo this is their
territory and and the law and order
and combating this insurgency primarily
lies there
coming up after the break vaccines are
helping the u.s bounce back from the
pandemic
but how can we get vaccines to
marginalized communities
more when we come back
access the financial world on demand
hear from leading economists
policymakers
and industry experts via live and
on-demand webinars
only from bloomberg
start exploring to see what's moving the
markets
visit bloomberg.com webinars
our generation's biggest problem climate
change
is happening and the world's most
innovative solutions
transport industry buildings electricity
all of those things everything you need
to know about our changing environment
the politics of global warming we can
and we will deal with climate change
in the fight against climate change
bloomberg green has you covered
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
for some people in the u.s pre-pandemic
life feels closer than ever because of
the increasingly speedy
vaccine rollout but one harsh reality is
that marginalized communities are not
getting equal access to the shots
quick takes matthew albany spoke with
city lab sarah holder about one solution
to fight that
sarah thanks for joining us so we've
seen a lot of milestones in the u.s when
it comes to the vaccine rollout
but obviously there's still a lot of
work that needs to be done
where is the country standing right now
thanks for having me um yeah in the u.s
the vaccine roller has been
accelerating in the past few weeks um
according to bloomberg's vaccine tracker
169 million doses have been given so far
in the us that's an average of
three million doses a day in the past
week an eligibility requirements are
loosening in many states you know uh
people 16 and up
uh will be able to get the vaccine in
many states
by mid april including in california um
meanwhile of course there are also
variants of concern that are spreading
around the country and public health
experts have warned that
if we don't get those under control by
the time that we
get more of the population vaccinated
there could be the potential for
a fourth wave but people are hoping that
a vaccine rollout will continue
um to accelerate uh to fend that wave
off
right and that's one of the things that
i wanted to bring up when it comes to
the conversation of vaccine roll out
there's been
a lot of conversation about it going
towards
mainly affluent areas and
based on your piece i wanted to talk
about what are some of the barriers that
people are having when it comes to
accessing this
and you know are there any strategies
that are being implemented
to help educate people and also help the
vaccines
you know help people get the vaccines
that they need absolutely i mean you
mentioned the geographic and the income
disparities in the rollout you know
in some states you can really see the
disparity
county to county that richer counties
are getting vaccines
faster than poorer counties or that even
within
cities you know different zip codes are
more vaccinated than others so i've
specifically reported on mobile
vaccination units
um so in many counties especially in
northern california but there are few
across the country these are sort of
roving teams of emts and nurses who can
go into these
you know low-income senior housing or
shelter systems
and bring vaccines to folks who can't
make the trek or make an appointment
themselves
and also they've been deploying vaccine
vans
mobile vaccine vans in some cases so
outside of the big
you know javits center moscone center um
these are roving vans that can park in
parking lots and zip codes that again
uh perhaps were harder hit underserved
have high populations of hispanic
residents
black residents and really target the
the people who haven't
yet been targeted in a concerted enough
way
and so i'm really fascinated by you know
the idea of these mobile vaccine units
what does a typical day
look like for them and uh you know what
are their
goals specifically when it comes to
reaching these communities
yeah so i spent a couple of days with a
mobile vaccination van and a mobile
vaccination unit in marin county which
is in
northern california just across the
golden gate bridge from san francisco
where i'm based
and the mobile vaccine unit as i
mentioned has nurses and emts they
come into a facility with a cooler of
vaccines the day that i was following
them they used
johnson and johnson so that's one shot
and then you're good to go
um they started at 8 30 in the morning
they set up in this low-income senior
housing facility
got their tables and their syringes set
up and and started
going through people who had either
signed up to get
an appointment based on outreach from
their facility staff
or people who just walked in they were
also vaccinating
staff members who interact with these
older
residents on the daily and
then you know doing what you would see
in some of these centralized facilities
except
right in these people's you know
backyards basically
and for some people who were homebound
who couldn't even leave their apartments
to get recreation room where these
vaccinations are happening
nurses would go into their apartments
and give them a shot right in their
on their couch or in their chairs
um so this truly was really reaching the
people
you know the most vulnerable of the most
vulnerable the people who couldn't find
another way
you know among the nurses and the emts
too there's a sense that it's
that it's you know great to be a part of
um a strategy like this and to really be
reaching out to
to people where they are um and in marin
county for example
but it is a really unequal place and and
um so this is a really
concerted effort again to bridge those
gaps and shrink those disparities
and so far i think the mobile outreach
teams which are like the
mobile units i'm talking about and the
van that parks and in parking lots
across the county
um have have done thousands and
thousands of jobs about 8
000 shots so far and they're you know
going to new places
every single day all right bloomberg
city lab sarah holder thank you so much
for giving
us some perspective on a unique solution
that's really
seeming to pay off thank you so much
quick thanks matthew albany thanks so
much for that report
all right now for today's movers and
shakers the people impacting the world
of business politics and sports
representative matt gates reportedly
asked the white house for blanket
pre-emptive pardons last year
that request was made during the final
weeks of donald trump's turn
according to the nyt the florida
republican's push for a pardon coincided
with the justice department
starting its investigation into sex
trafficking allegations
against him gates says he's innocent and
denied that her pardon request was
related to the investigation
new york governor andrew cuomo says
newly announced tax hikes on the state's
wealthy
could be significantly offset if there's
a repeal on the federal cap on state and
local tax deductions
cuomo says he's spoken to president
biden and fully expects the current 10
000
cap implemented by former president
trump to get repealed
he says that will lower net taxes by
more than 30 percent
and john wilson apparent accused in the
college admissions scandal who is
currently awaiting trial
is suing netflix for defamation
according to wilson's lawyers
the streaming giant's portrayal of
wilson in a new documentary about
operation varsity blues could lead to an
unfair trial
wilson also alleges that the movie
defamed him netflix did not respond to
requests for comment
and those are your movers and shakers
for today
now still ahead we'll tell you about
surprising new research
shining a light on just how eager
americans are to travel again
stick with us
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
access the financial world on demand
[Music]
hear from leading economists
policymakers
and industry experts via live and
on-demand webinars
only from bloomberg
start exploring to see what's moving the
markets
visit bloomberg.com webinars
[Music]
all right the number of americans
traveling through airports hit
another pandemic high today as the
vaccine rollout is getting more people
excited to travel
on average daily passenger numbers
exceeded 1.4 million last week
which is about 35 below pre-pandemic
levels from the start of 2020
but despite leisure travel rebounding
our next guest says
business travel may actually never
recover to those same
levels glenn fogle is ceo of booking
holdings whose subsidiaries include
booking.com priceline and kayak glenn
thank you so much for joining us
your company commissioned some really
interesting research on how people plan
to travel so glenn before we get into
that first of i just want to know
what is the number one place on your
travel bucket list where are you going
first
well first place i have to go when it's
open i need to go to
europe and thank you so much for having
me because travel right now
everybody wants to go i want to go but
amsterdam is for our headquarters for
booking.com
and i haven't seen those people now for
over a year so i've got to get over
there
absolutely europe is definitely on the
list and we're all watching the clock
waiting for the opportunity to be able
to safely travel again
i want to dig into a couple of numbers
here from your reporting and your
research on
travel and how excited people are for it
71
of americans are eager to travel because
of vaccines
61 percent say they've realized travel
is critical to their emotional
well-being
and 60 say travel is more important now
than before the pandemic started
so that's just you know a couple of data
points but i know you've got a lot more
what's one data point that really sticks
out to you and highlights
just how much people want to be
traveling again you know that issue
people wanting to travel more than
finding a romantic partner is just
remarkable to me
um i guess maybe the travel doesn't talk
back to you doesn't argue with you
and it gives you great pleasure no
matter what maybe that's what's going on
there but
look there's a lot of interesting uh
statistics but you don't need statistics
to know
people want to get going and we want to
help people travel and that's why
we have an incredible promotion right
now if you go to the booking.com app
and you pick a place and you stay we're
going to give you a 50
credit to do it again because we know
everybody wants to travel
but we know from those numbers you just
gave out the numbers are still below
where they were in 2019 we've got to get
this industry back and up and running
one way to do it give people credit to
get them going
are you concerned at all that despite
these findings from your reporting that
you know people
are still reticent to travel then
they're just not feeling fully safe
doing it yet
well i think that people are feeling
safer and safer as things come along and
as more and more people get their
vaccination they feel safer
we see that from the statistics too so
we know
as the rollout continues people are
going to feel safer
and plan now get that vacation now
blocked up book it while the prices have
not risen a lot
and that way you'll be ready when you'll
feel even better in the summer and
you'll have a place to go
i want to ask you about what
responsibility the tourism the tourism
industry has
related to the pandemic because you know
of course we are seeing this vaccine
roll out very exciting but we're also
seeing cases continue to go
up so what do you think the tourism
industry
needs to do to continue to keep people
safe even as it does feel to some that
the pandemic is coming to a close
well we have been saying from the very
beginning how important safety is and
safety first beyond
everything we want safety before
business and the thing everybody needs
to do
is follow the guidelines that are issued
by authorities like the cdc
who now is saying if you are vaccinated
it is safe to travel
but we always say please wear your mask
where you're supposed to wear a mask
please just follow the distance rules
when you are in places where they ask
you to be distanced
if everybody would just follow the rules
we'd be through this back
virus thing so much quicker and i also
want to ask you about one form of travel
that people may not be missing which is
business related travel i think some
folks are very excited that they've
gotten to have their meetings over
zoom companies are excited that they
haven't had to pay for that
but why do you think that consumers
should care
about a lack of business travel moving
forward what impact does that have
you know it's really going to be
interesting because the airlines and the
higher start hotels
made a lot of their profits on business
travel let's face it people in the front
of that plane
at that business class seat or the first
classes
that was a lot of the profits now
without that travel
the economics of the airlines is going
to change and that those big hotels that
cater to business people
that can make a lot of change in terms
of service in terms of frequencies in
terms of how crowded the planes will be
they're going to be some changes coming
you know i i i'm concerned that there
could be some
more crowded planes as they try as
planes try they try to make profits by
just cramming more people in
and will business travel ever recover
moving forward in your view
well i think eventually the total amount
of business travel will be greater than
2019 just as
our economies around the world grow and
people travel more and more there will
be more business travel
but i think forever it'll be a lower
share of total travel
because people can now do so many types
of communication that
in the past we wouldn't have used so in
the past i would have traveled for a
full day just to have a two-hour meeting
i'm not going to do that anymore i'm
going to do video communication like
we're doing
absolutely well glenn fogle thank you so
much for joining us ceo of booking.com
all right let's get you a look at some
of the day's top tech headlines
it looks like twitter was in talks to
choir clubhouse for
whopping 4 billion sources tell
bloomberg news that talks were held in
recent months
though it's not entirely clear why the
negotiation stalled
earlier this week bloomberg news
reported clubhouse is looking to start a
fundraising round
seeking a four billion dollar valuation
and apple is making it easier to keep
track of some of your things
the company updated its find my service
to locate items from non-apple
manufacturers
starting next week users can find their
van move ebikes chipolo item trackers
and belkin wireless earbuds using the
find my app on iphones
or any web connected device via icloud
and pinterest is preparing some new
features to keep its community
free of toxic behaviors the social
network is launching its creator code
a content policy with guidelines aimed
at keeping pinterest quote a positive
and inspiring place
creators on pinterest will have to sign
on the creator code
before being able to publish story pins
the creator code will start rolling out
in the next few weeks
for the latest tech news
bookmarkbloomberg.com forward slash
technology
and coming up after the break could the
filibuster's days be numbered we'll talk
to a bloomberg opinion writer about why
the procedure may be fading away
access the financial world on demand
hear from leading economists
policymakers
and industry experts via live and
on-demand webinars
only from bloomberg
start exploring to see what's moving the
markets
visit bloomberg.com webinars
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
our generation's biggest problem climate
change
is happening and the world's most
innovative solutions
transport industry buildings electricity
all of those things
everything you need to know about our
changing environment the politics of
global warming
we can and we will deal with climate
change in the fight against climate
change
bloomberg green has you covered
[Music]
[Music]
president biden is pressing ahead on his
two trillion dollar infrastructure plan
that's despite opposition from
republicans who are hesitant to commit
to
getting behind the scale of the plan and
the tax increases needed to fund it
but there are increasing signs that the
plan may move ahead despite that
opposition
some democratic party lawmakers are
looking to bring an end to one tool
republicans
may look to to hold up the progress and
that tool is the filibuster
here to tell us more about the possible
future of that tool is bloomberg opinion
writer jonathan bernstein jonathan
thanks so much for being here
president biden has been hesitant to
come out firmly in support of
ending the filibuster but at the same
time we're seeing him push ahead on the
tax hike and
all of these really progressive plans
like tomorrow he's planning to announce
this
gun violence plan what's the likelihood
of the current filibuster process as we
know it coming to an end
before biden has to push through on
these policies
it's not real real likely to end very
soon
um although there's a lot of uncertainty
about that
mainly because right now the democrats
have such a narrow margin in the senate
they only have
you know a 50-50 tie with the vice
president breaking the tie
if there were 52 or 53 democratic
senators right now
the filibuster would basically be dead
do we need to get rid of the filibuster
for or does biden need to get rid of the
filibuster to get these progressive
policies
moving forward well what's happening
because they don't have the votes to get
rid of the filibuster altogether
what's happening is they're pushing
around the margins and we just don't
know
how to what extent senator manchin
uh center cinema the more marginal
democratic senators are willing to do
that but for example we've seen already
now that um chuck schumer the democratic
leader
has uh found a new a new wrinkle
in reconciliation procedures which is a
way to get
through the senate without uh being
subject to a filibuster so that
where once upon a time you could do that
once in a congress
then republicans found a way to do it
maybe twice during congress and now
uh senator schumer has found ways to do
it maybe several times per congress
so uh we're look we're moving in the
direction of
perhaps finding little bullet holes to
put
through the filibuster um senator
feinstein today
said that she was willing to uh vote to
get rid of the filibuster when it came
to voting rights
i don't think there's 50 votes yet to do
that but there could be
over the course of this congress what do
you make of the far
left or mid-left's reaction to biden
not coming out firmly against the
filibuster do you think that that's fair
uh you know he's not a senator anymore
he doesn't have a vote
um ultimately this is whether all 50
democratic senators are going to be for
it
and you know senator joe manchin of west
virginia
doesn't have to listen to joe biden he
doesn't have to listen to
um very liberal democrats he has to
listen to
his own feelings about what he wants to
get on what he thinks will help him for
reelection
and so biden is sort of irrelevant to
all this process the main process is
our job joe manchin are senator cinema
and other marginal you know moderately
liberal democrats going to get so
frustrated about not passing things
that they will go ahead and change the
rules so we've talked about the
opposition to the filibuster but is
there an argument for it can you tell me
about the pros
yeah the the case for the filibuster
over time has basically been
that it already it gives individual
senators
more influence within the senate than
they would have otherwise than
for example the house everything runs
basically by majority party fiat
uh you know whatever the majority party
says that's what happens in the senate
individual senators have been able to
cut deals and make bargains
over time because parties have become
more important in american politics
that's become less and less important to
those individual senators so that
most democrats right now and most
republicans when the republicans have
the majority
are very interested in cross-party
coalition they're not interested in
getting their own
individual measures through their
interest in helping their party
and that's why the filibuster is
probably doomed because
senators individual senators no longer
care very much about
their own personal influence within the
senate i'm going to quickly jonathan ask
you to see the future for me how long do
you think it's going to take for
your vision of what's going to happen to
the filibuster to come to life
certainly the next time we have a
unified government with
a strong with 54 56 um
senators the majority that will be the
end of it it's possible though it could
end even earlier
all right jonathan bernstein thanks so
much for that now coming up after the
break in a world of big wind
is there a place for tiny turbines we'll
hear more about how
some companies are carving out space for
smaller turbines
in the energy energy industry next
[Music]
[Music]
access the financial world on demand
hear from leading economists
policymakers
and industry experts via live and
on-demand webinars
only from bloomberg
start exploring to see what's moving the
markets
visit bloomberg.com webinars
[Music]
small wind turbines have been around for
decades but they've struggled to carve
out a dedicated market space
the tiny equipment has also struggled to
compete with solar for small-scale
applications
but that's all changing now one
australian company is a niche market for
tiny turbines
joining us now to discuss this is
bloomberg news reporter georgie mckay
georgie thanks so much for being here
we just described this niche market but
in your own words
tell me what trends you found in your
reporting about this sure hi madison
so diffuse energy has developed a tiny
turbine
it's about the height of a large
standing fan that's less than three feet
wide and lighter than a pickup
truck tire which is quite uncommon when
the rest
of the largest wind companies in the
world are developing these
crazy big turbines but this company's
our ceo and co-founder was initially
researching the use of this small wind
technology
to power onboard systems of yachts but
he said it was hard to get investors
excited about
giving your owners an extra week or two
of power outage
so the company pivoted when a
telecommunications company became
interested in the product
to attach the turbine to the top of the
telecommunications tower
and integrate this product into existing
solar and battery systems
and this uh pivot i suppose to
small wind isn't uncommon it's been done
before there's
the a s 311 who is producing a similar
small wind turbine
uh it's extremely light and the company
said it could be picked up by a small
child and this product has been picked
up by the o2 arena
in london to power the entire stadium
which is pretty cool
georgie i think it's fair for us to take
a second to talk about how these are
very cute tiny turbines right
yes for sure and taking a step back you
know it's obviously more important than
the cuteness and smallness here
why should we care about wind turbines
and telecommunication sites what are the
implications
i think the most important part of this
is that
a small wind turbine can replace the
need for diesel
which is obviously great for the
environment and it also can provide
a reliable energy source when i was
speaking to
um the company's co-founder he said that
telecommunications companies in
australia and in other countries as well
the the towers are in these remote areas
and they're often affected by fire and
floods
so by having a diesel generator if you
can't access the site
you can't repair it and then that
threatens people being able to use their
phone in a disaster sort of situation
so by installing a small wind turbine
you can
effectively ensure that there is power
around the clock when a natural disaster
strikes
right when i was reading your story i
was reminded of the texas power grid
failure
that we had in the us following you know
huge snowstorm
is this one way that we could
potentially avoid events like that in
the future
um i suppose so yes it's it's perfect
for
these remote sites and for i think
the best part about this technology is
that it can be applied to
certain niche situations and it can
off-grid power supply could be a good
example of where this small scale
turbine
might work so you can put it in a remote
mine size you can put it in the forest
on a telco
tower you can give it to a village
that's
far away from the grid the company
mentioned in indonesia where
there's uh it's very difficult to access
a centralized power grid just because of
the geography that
the country is made up of some 17 000
islands
so in in this case this product perfect
when
they're not traditional geography and
power
availability and this comes even as the
world is looking to build the biggest
turbines ever so is there a place
for small turbines absolutely i don't
think
these companies both the fuse and alpha
311 they aren't trying to replace
power um stations they're never going to
be able to offer that
extremely large power supply but
they can support these niche situations
such as powering telco sites or powering
the o2 arena or some other things that i
mentioned
off the grid mine sites and everything
so when it's applied and the geography
is perfect for these
um for this technology to thrive then
yes it does have a place
but um not on a large scale as large as
these massive turbines we're seeing or
possibly even
solar because solar is still just so
much deeper
all right georgie mckay thanks so much
for joining us and that does it for
quick take this hour you can check out
the latest stories at bloomberg.com or
at quick take on social media
have a good night everyone
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
coming up on quick take the lead a new
warning from the uk
on the heavily debated astrazeneca
vaccine
healthy people under 30 are being
offered an alternative shot
what we know about evidence of rare
blood clots associated with the jab
then with summer approaching and more
people getting vaccinated a lot of us
are really excited to travel again
we'll speak to the ceo of the largest
online travel company to find out
where americans are most eager to go
next
and a possible political game changer to
keep president biden's two
trillion dollar infrastructure package
on track
we'll tell you what you need to know
about the important us filibuster
it's wednesday april 7th i'm madison
mills those stories and more coming up
on quick take the lead
[Music]
we start today with news of the
embattled astrazeneca coveted 19 vaccine
eu pharmaceutical regulators announce a
possible link between the shot and blood
clots although they do claim that it's
very rare
questions about the shot's safety have
emerged in recent weeks
and several european countries briefly
suspended their use of the vaccine last
month
now the uk joint committee on
vaccination and immunization
has decided it's safer to advise people
aged 18 to 29
to get a different shot whenever
possible they still contend that the
overall benefits of the astrazeneca shot
far outweigh the risks in some cases
there is still
a benefit to younger people from
being vaccinated and overall that
benefit
is still in favor of being vaccinated
it happens that where we have an
alternative vaccine
we feel on balance it would be
preferable
to offer the very youngest people who
have no other health conditions
the alternative vaccine instead of the
estrogenical vaccine
to help make sense of these findings
we're joined by dr susannah hills from
columbia university medical center dr
hills thanks so much for
being here i'm hoping to get some
clarity from you because i
certainly didn't get it from today's
presser we're hearing that the shot is
potentially causing clots but it's also
unlikely but also don't take it if
you're too young it's a little bit of
whiplash here
so what was your takeaway from today's
astrazeneca news
right i think the the punchline
of today's news really is that
this vaccine is still incredibly safe
we just have to keep it in perspective
um
the vaccine has been shown to be 75
effective in preventing symptomatic
covaid it's nearly 100 effective
in preventing hospitalizations and
deaths from cobit 19.
so those are incredible results and the
benefits here
really outweigh the very tiny risk
that they're talking about which are
these brain clots they've given about 25
million doses of this vaccine and
they've had i think
64 cases of clots in the brain
and an additional 28 in the abdomen i
believe
so the numbers of the clots are just so
so low
right and the benefit is really
outweighing the risk here i think
right and i want to dig into another
number associated with what you just
mentioned doctor which is that the mhra
said today that the clotting is very
rare but they gathered
some data that they presented
specifically regarding young people that
i want to point out they
basically said that the risk is just a
little bit more present for
younger younger individuals that the
risk of clots is four in a million
that number sounds low so do you think
that there's a chance that we
freaked out a little prematurely here
and might discourage
younger people from even getting their
shots
that's the concern right um
every as we're learning more and more
about this disease and about the
vaccines that can help prevent it
we have to you know take things in
perspective
and and you know take the long view um
so we are going to learn more as we get
more information
guidelines are going to change and it's
going to require people to be a little
bit flexible in the guidance that's
given
but this kind of low
low low incidence of this complication
really in terms of the other things that
we recommend
like you know a daily aspirin for
example um
for preventing you know complications of
heart attacks
i mean about you know two and a thousand
people are going to have
a significant stroke or brain bleed
related to that
that's a much higher risk and yet
because it saves lives we still
recommend it all the time
so if we try to keep things in
perspective i think you know looking at
the you know over 550 000 people that
have died
over 30 million cases and the clear
benefit
of this vaccine that can you know really
keep almost 100
percent of people out of the hospital um
that's that's the thing to focus on
and i feel like i'm getting more clarity
from you than i did in these
pressers today i'm curious about you
know in the uk they said that if you're
30 or if you're 31 if you're on that
line you're just gonna have to make the
decision yourself it's really up to you
what's behind this lack of clarity here
are regulators just
afraid that they might um you know say
something they have to go back on later
or
why why is there such vagueness right
now
yeah yeah well i think we have business
right now because we just don't have the
data
to fully answer these questions um the
clinical trials that were done weren't
designed to look at these risks in an
age stratified sense
so you know looking at complications in
30 versus 31 versus 50 50.
they weren't really designed that way
and
when the the study populations in the
original clinical trials
were were relatively although they
contained tens of thousands of people
relatively small right
so when you're talking about a hand you
know a handful in
25 million vaccine doses administered of
having clots
you're not going to pick up enough cases
of clots in the populations that were
measured in the first clinical trials
that were really truly rigorous trials
with rigorous answers
so the best they can do right now is
share information and
and then you know give more concrete
guidance as we have more data
dr hills in our final minute here
pregnant people and children what should
they be thinking about the astro shot
yeah i you know it's natural for
everybody to take their own personal
medical history
and you know take that into account
people who have
i think we might be losing dr hills oh
you're back okay i'm sorry go ahead
sorry about that yeah so you know
pregnant women have an increased risk
of clotting people of clotting disorders
may think about this vaccine differently
but even still when you're talking about
this low of a number of cases of this
happening
i still would say this vaccine is
incredibly safe i think it's important
to relay that message because we need
this vaccine
and we need people to feel comfortable
taking it and we have
every reason to think it's still going
to be safe and extremely effective
dr hills really appreciate you joining
us and clearing that up thank you so
much
now let's get you some other coronavirus
headlines from around the world
the international monetary fund says
governments should consider
a wealth tax to help cover the cost of
the pandemic
as inequality has widened due to the
virus the imf is making the case that
those better off
should be asked to pay more on a
temporary basis in an interview with
bloomberg's tom keane
imf managing director kristelina
giorgiva said the vaccines
also play a big role we provide
clear and compelling case for
accelerating vaccinations everywhere
the world economy is going to be 9
trillion dollars richer between now
and 2025 if vaccinations
are accelerated and if countries like
brazil
and india are in a position to do
more to get out of the health crisis
and according to the first large-scale
research on the coronavirus
one in three people who were severely
ill with covid
were subsequently diagnosed with a
neurological or psychiatric condition
the university of oxford study found
that anxiety was the most
common condition to develop six months
after getting infected with the virus
while researchers found no specific
causes of these long-term effects
they suggest it could be linked to
stress job losses or even loneliness
and beijing is putting up color-coded
signs on buildings that indicate
what percentage of workers inside have
been vaccinated
the city's financial district is leading
the campaign to green code its buildings
locations get a green circular sign if
over 80 percent of those working inside
have gotten their shots
government officials say the move is
aimed at accelerating the vaccine
rollout
now for the latest covent news
bookmarkbloomberg.com forward slash
coronavirus
and coming up after the break the us
economy will boom into 2023
but inequality needs to be addressed we
break down key points from jp morgan ceo
jamie dimon's annual letter
sure
[Music]
[Music]
access the financial world on demand
hear from leading economists
policymakers
and industry experts via live and
on-demand webinars
only from bloomberg
start exploring to see what's moving the
markets
visit bloomberg.com webinars
our generation's biggest problem climate
change
is happening and the world's most
innovative solutions
transport industry uh buildings
electricity
all of those things everything you need
to know about our changing environment
the politics of global warming we can
and we will deal with climate change
in the fight against climate change
bloomberg green has you covered
[Music]
[Music]
jamie dimon who built one of the most
profitable banks in u.s history
is sounding the alarm on the future of
american prosperity
in an annual letter to shareholders the
j.p morgan ceo
said that the pandemic and the murder of
george floyd have exposed
long-standing and profound inequities
diamond wrote
many of our citizens are unsettled and
the fault line for all of this discord
is fraying the american dream the
enormous wealth in this country
is accruing to the very few his letter
comes as companies and business leaders
face
pressure to take a stand on important
social issues ranging from voting rights
to racism and
inequality as a whole so joining us now
to discuss is bloomberg banking reporter
hannah levitt hannah thanks for being
here
first off i want to take a big step back
for those who aren't familiar who is
jamie dimon
and what is he staying saying about the
state of inequality in the us here
yeah so thank you for having me um jamie
dimon is the ceo of jpmorgan which is
the biggest u.s bank
and additionally it's one of the biggest
biggest companies
in the country um and it has a huge you
know employee base
um and he's also been around a long time
he's been ceo of jp morgan since the end
of 2005.
um so today he put out his annual
shareholder letter and this is something
he does every year
um this year's was the longest yet it
was 66 pages
um and you know one one of the biggest
issues that he hit on was just lamenting
the inequality
um in this country and the effects of
you know like you said the pandemic and
the murder of george floyd and
in the role that those played exposing
that
so besides the crowd of bankers who are
going to be interested in reading this
why does it matter what diamond has to
say what's the potential impact here
yeah so look jamie dimon is incredibly
influential as a business curtain
person he's very influential around the
world and
within the us and if you think about you
know he's kind of a spokesperson
for the banking industry um and a lot of
a lot of
banks specifically tend to follow what
what jp morgan
says and what jamie dimon says uh so so
he really he wields that influence
you know across the country and he's not
new to kind of influencing these
cultural
social justice conversations he's made
these comments for quite some time now
what was surprising to you about the
comments in this 66-page letter
uh that came out today yeah that's
correct um
what what stood out to me was just the
the amount of space dedicated
to these issues and uh really making the
economic case for fixing them which he's
done before but
66 pages is very long um
and so we saw a lot of that today what
did you make of the length of the letter
why
why did it need to be that long um i
think because 2020 was a long year right
right fair enough fair enough uh that
definitely makes sense given 2020.
i do want to talk a little bit about the
flip side of this
which you know what comes to mind is his
taxes in 2020
his annual salary was 31.5 million
dollars and
you know he's he's talking about wealth
inequality uh
what's his position on how his own
wealth plays into income inequality as a
whole
yeah so jamie dimon is a billionaire um
and that's important to note we've seen
the the backlash against billionaires
for years
um but he he's advocated for
a lower a competitive corporate tax
which means
lower um but he seems to be okay with
taxing
the wealthy like him more um and that
you know he said in his letter today
that wealthy people should keep in mind
that
if their tax dollars go to better you
know society and the economy that they
ultimately benefit as well
and diamonds comments come in the wave
of corporations and ceos speaking out
about social justice issues we're seeing
all of these ceos speaking out about
voting rights restrictions in the state
of georgia for example
i'm curious are these comments from
diamond uh just
good pr because this is expected of ceos
right now or is this
genuine yeah so look um
i think there are multiple factors at
play here first of all
jamie dimon and jp morgan have a lot of
people
dedicated to you know staying in tune
with this stuff whether it be
people in like pr people or lobbyist
people in washington etc
um but at the same time i mean he's he's
always been
outspoken um and so
yeah of course i mean of course
corporations can do more we've seen
we've seen them
uh step up a bit in the past year but of
course there's always room to do more
but at the same time
diamond seems to um you know he makes an
economic case for it
uh which i think is worth noting and
he's talked about running for president
before do you think that this had any
political ambition behind it
or was it again was it genuine yeah look
so there's there's been speculation um
every cycle uh and as these annual
letters have
which has been doing these forever but
they've gotten longer and dedicating
more space
um but he's shut that down so
yeah fair enough bloomberg's hannah
levitt thank you so much for joining us
appreciate it
all right in minneapolis the trial of
derek chauvin did continue today
the jury heard from jody steiger a los
angeles police department sergeant and
use of force expert
steiger said that chauvin never took his
knee off george floyd's neck
from the time officers put him on the
ground until paramedics arrived
and you tell the jury at what point in
time in your opinion does the restraint
itself begin
based on my review of the body worn
video
the restraint started at
20 19 and 14 seconds
and when does the restraint period and
i believe it was 20 28 and 43 seconds
and sir what is the duration then of
that time period the restraint period
nine minutes and 29 seconds
steiger's testimony came a day after
chauvin's attorney eric nelson
sought to point out moments in the video
footage when he said
chauvin's knee did not appear to be on
floyd's neck
chauvin is charged with murder and
manslaughter in floyd's death
last may and in other news from around
the world
an iranian ship believed to be a base
for the paramilitary revolutionary guard
has been attacked in the red sea that's
according to the country's local
government
local officials suspect the attack was
carried out by israel
the assault came as iran and several
world powers met in vienna to try and
resurrect the tattered nuclear deal
some experts do say the ship which has
been anchored in the red sea for years
has provided arms and support to yemen's
houthi rebels
iran has previously described the vessel
as aiding in anti-piracy efforts
and in turkey a visit from two top
european officials is igniting
conversation over
gender equality tv images show only two
chairs
were available when president erdogan
met with ursula vonderlein and charles
michelle
as michelle took the seat next to
erdogan vonderlyne was left standing
and eventually took the seat of a second
rank official on a nearby couch
brussels had this to say about the
incident the president
should have been seated exactly in the
same manner
as the president of the european council
and the
and the turkish president
but as i said she decided to proceed
nevertheless
prioritizing substance over protocol
and rwandan president paul gagami is
praising the french report documenting
france's role in the 1994 genocide
he says the rwandan government
interpreted the report as
saying france knew that a genocide
against the tutsis
was being planned by their rwandis
allies but continued to support them
france says its report clears it of
complicity in the massacres
this week marks the anniversary of the
beginning of the genocide that left
nearly 1 million people dead for the
latest news from your part of the world
go to bloomberg.com click on the
addition drop down right next to the
bloomberg masthead and choose your
region
and staying in africa jihadis in
mozambique forced the french energy firm
total
to suspend work at its multi-billion
dollar liquefied
natural gas project in the country next
up quick takes mark daniel davies
explains the conflict's origin
and what it could mean for southern
africa's economic development
this 20 billion dollar natural gas
project in northern mozambique
is the single biggest private investment
in africa
the government here hopes to reap as
much as 100 billion dollars in revenue
over the next 25 years
that's more than six times the country's
annual gdp
but what's meant to be a gas bonanza for
one of the world's poorest countries
is developing alongside a deadly
insurgency
i'm mark davies for bloomberg quick take
here's what you need to know
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
since 2017 more than 2 600 people have
died
and 700 000 displaced as violent attacks
spread in the cabo delgado province
in march dozens of people were killed in
a raid by islamist militants just a few
miles from the project
site french gas giant total in response
halted operations on its 20 billion
venture for a second time
in 2021
they have done horrific things they are
still doing so they had seen bodies
laying on the streets
thousands are making their way by foot
boat and road
some are being rescued by the un's
humanitarian air services
evidence suggests insurgents in
mozambique's north began
as an islamist sect in 2007.
by the mid-2010s it had shifted to armed
jihadism
the group carrying out attacks in the
capital guard is known as al-shabab
al-shabab just means a day off in arab
there is no non-leakage with the group
with the same name
operating in somalia the first attack
happened in 2017
but the group activity in terms of
radicalization
can be trusted five years before i think
that
much of this really has to do with
smuggling syndicates
that have been operating for decades for
generations in the area
this is a really rural marginalized area
and they
they therefore serve as a very fertile
ground for for recruitment
and the only source in a sense of
employment of opportunity
is through smuggling networks and
through
radicals that offer them some payment
and some money
and it seems like the smugglers are
partly attempting to protect
their smuggling roots and and building
on local
frustrations about the potential mass
gas exploration that is developing are
able to recruit locals
[Music]
mozambique's army has struggled to
contain the violence so far
it's brought in russian and south
african private military companies to
quell attacks
with very little success more recently
the state has started social programs
targeting vulnerable young people this
in hopes of addressing discontent over a
lack of jobs and opportunities
but for now the conflict continues
the results uh are very poor even with
this
assistance from private military company
this group manages to attack and occupy
five district headquarters so five towns
that is huge in less than a year
mozambique
fought a civil war 16-year civil war and
did not see such such a situation of
attacking and occupying district towns
like what is happening here
the region and regional governments like
south africa have long been aware of the
emerging problem but the government in
maputo like most governments have said
guys this is a national problem uh we
will deal with this nationally
there's a lot that southern africa
the africa union and the international
community can do
but eventually it's all dependent upon
the
world and the capacity of the government
in maputo this is their territory and
and the law and order and combating this
insurgency primarily
lies there
coming up after the break vaccines are
helping the u.s bounce back from the
pandemic
but how can we get vaccines to
marginalized communities
more when we come back
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
access the financial world on demand
[Music]
hear from leading economists
policymakers
and industry experts via live and
on-demand
webinars only from bloomberg
start exploring to see what's moving the
markets
visit bloomberg.com webinars
[Music]
[Music]
for some people in the u.s pre-pandemic
life feels closer than ever because of
the increasingly speedy vaccine rollout
but one harsh reality is that
marginalized communities are not getting
equal access to the shots
quick takes matthew albany spoke with
city lab sarah holder about
one solution to fight that
sarah thanks for joining us so we've
seen a lot of milestones in the us when
it comes to the vaccine roll out
but obviously there's still a lot of
work that needs to be done
where is the country standing right now
thanks for having me um yeah in the u.s
the vaccine rollout has been
accelerating in the past few weeks
according to bloomberg's vaccine tracker
169 million doses have been given so far
in the u.s that's an average of three
million doses a day in the past week
and eligibility requirements are
loosening in many states you know
people 16 and up will be able to get the
vaccine in many states
um by mid-april including in california
um meanwhile of course there are also
variants of concern that are spreading
around the country and public health
experts have warned that
if we don't get those under control by
the time that we uh get
more of the population vaccinated there
could be the potential for
a fourth wave um but people are hoping
that
a vaccine rollout will continue um to
accelerate
uh to fend that wave off right and
that's
one of the things that i wanted to bring
up when it comes to the conversation of
vaccine rollout there's been a
a lot of conversation about it going
towards mainly affluent areas
and based on your piece i wanted to talk
about
what are some of the barriers that
people are having when it comes to
accessing this
and you know are there any strategies
that are being implemented to help
educate people and also
help the vaccines you know help people
get the vaccines that they need
absolutely i mean you mentioned the
geographic and the income disparities in
the rollout you know
in some states you can really see the
disparity
county to county that richer counties
are getting vaccines
faster than poorer counties or that even
within
cities you know different zip codes are
more vaccinated than others so i
specifically reported on mobile
vaccination units
um so in many counties especially in
northern california but there are few
across the country these are sort of
roving teams of emts and nurses who can
go into these
you know low-income senior housing or
shelter systems
and bring vaccines to folks who can't
make the trek or make an appointment
themselves
and also they've been deploying vaccine
vans
mobile vaccine vans in some cases so
outside of the big
you know javits center moscone center
these are roving vans that can park in
parking lots and zip codes that again
uh perhaps were harder hit underserved
have high populations of
hispanic residents to black residents
and really target
the the people who haven't yet been
targeted in a concerted enough way
and so i'm really fascinated by you know
the idea of these mobile vaccine units
what does a typical
day look like for them and you know what
are their
goals specifically when it comes to
reaching these communities
yeah so i spent a couple of days with a
mobile vaccination van
and a mobile vaccination unit in marin
county which is in
northern california just across the
golden gate bridge from san francisco
where i'm based
and the mobile vaccine unit as i
mentioned has nurses and emts
they come into a facility with a cooler
of vaccines
the day that i was following them they
used johnson and johnson so that's one
shot and then you're good to go
um they started at 8 30 in the morning
they set up in this low-income senior
housing facility
got their tables and their syringes set
up and and started
going through people who had either
signed up to get
an appointment based on outreach from
their facility staff
or people who just walked in they were
also vaccinating
staff members who interact with these
older residents
on the daily and then you know
doing what you would see in some of
these centralized facilities except
right in these people's you know
backyards basically
and for some people who were homebound
who couldn't even leave their apartments
to get recreation room where these
vaccinations are happening
nurses would go into their apartments
and give them a shot right in their
uh on their couch or in their chairs
um so this truly was really reaching the
people
you know the most vulnerable of the most
vulnerable the people who couldn't find
another way
you know among the nurses and the emts
too there's a sense
that it's that it's you know great to be
a part of
um a strategy like this and to really be
reaching out to
to people where they are um and in marin
county for example
but it is a really unequal place and and
um so this is a really concerted effort
again
to bridge those gaps and shrink those
disparities
and so far i think the mobile outreach
teams which are like the
mobile units i'm talking about and the
van that parks and in parking lots
across the county
um have have done thousands and
thousands of jobs about 8 000
shots um so far and they're you know
going to new places every single day
all right bloomberg city lab sarah
holder thank you so much for giving us
some perspective on
a unique solution that's really seeming
to pay off
thank you so much
quick takes matthew albany thanks so
much for that report
all right now for today's movers and
shakers the people impacting the world
of business politics and sports
representative matt gates reportedly
asked the white house for blanket
pre-emptive pardons last year
that request was made during the final
weeks of donald trump's turn
according to the nyt the florida
republican's push for a pardon coincided
with the justice department
starting its investigation into sex
trafficking allegations against him
gates says he's innocent and denied that
her pardon request was related to the
investigation
new york governor andrew cuomo says
newly announced tax hikes on the state's
wealthy
could be significantly offset if there's
a repeal on the federal cap on state and
local tax deductions
cuomo says he's spoken to president
biden and fully expects the current 10
000
cap implemented by former president
trump to get repealed
he says that will lower net taxes by
more than 30 percent
and john wilson a parent accused in the
college admissions scandal who is
currently awaiting trial
is suing netflix for defamation
according to wilson's lawyers the
streaming giant's portrayal of wilson in
a new documentary about
operation varsity blues could lead to an
unfair trial
wilson also alleges that the movie
defamed him netflix did not respond to
requests for comment
and those are your movers and shakers
for today
now still ahead we'll tell you about
surprising new research shining a light
on just how eager americans are to
travel again stick with us
our generation's biggest problem climate
change
is happening and the world's most
innovative solutions
transport industry uh buildings
electricity all of those things
everything you need to know about our
changing environment the politics of
global warming
we can and we will deal with climate
change in the fight against climate
change
bloomberg green has you covered
[Music]
[Music]
access the financial world on demand
hear from leading economists
policymakers
and industry experts via live and
on-demand webinars
only from bloomberg
start exploring to see what's moving the
markets
visit bloomberg.com webinars
[Music]
all right the number of americans
traveling through airports hit another
pandemic high today
as the vaccine rollout is getting more
people excited to travel
on average daily passenger numbers
exceeded 1.4 million last week
which is about 35 percent below
pre-pandemic levels from the start of
2020
but despite leisure travel rebounding
our next guest says
business travel may actually never
recover to those same
levels glenn fogle is ceo of booking
holdings whose subsidiaries include
booking.com priceline and kayak glenn
thank you so much for joining us
your company commissioned some really
interesting research on how people plan
to travel
so glenn before we get into that first i
just want to know
what is the number one place on your
travel bucket list where are you going
first
well first place i have to go when it's
open i need to go to
europe and thank you so much for having
me because travel right now
everybody wants to go i want to go but
amsterdam is for our headquarters for
booking.com
and i haven't seen those people now for
over a year so i've got to get over
there
absolutely europe is definitely on the
list and we're all watching the clock
waiting for the opportunity to be able
to safely travel again
i want to dig into a couple of numbers
here from your reporting and your
research
on travel and how excited people are for
it 71
of americans are eager to travel because
of vaccines
61 say they've realized travel is
critical to their emotional well-being
and 60 say travel is more important now
than before the pandemic started
so that's just you know a couple of data
points but i know you've got a lot more
what's one data point that really sticks
out to you
and highlights just how much people want
to be traveling again
you know that issue people wanting to
travel more than finding a romantic
partner is just remarkable to me
i guess maybe the travel doesn't talk
back to you doesn't argue with you
and it gives you a great pleasure no
matter what maybe that's what's going on
there but
look there's a lot of interesting
statistics but you don't need statistics
to know
people want to get going and we want to
help people travel and that's why
we have an incredible promotion right
now if you go to the booking.com
app and you pick a place and you stay
we're going to give you a fifty dollar
credit
to do it again because we know everybody
wants to travel but we know from those
numbers you just gave out
the numbers are still below where they
were in 2019 we've got to get this
industry back and
up and running one way to do it give
people credit to get them going
are you concerned at all that despite
these findings from your reporting
that you know people are still reticent
to travel then they're just not feeling
fully safe doing it yet
well i think that people are feeling
safer and safer as things come along and
as more and more people get their
vaccination they feel safer
we see that from the statistics too so
we know
as the rollout continues people are
going to feel safer
and plan now get that vacation now
blocked up book it while the prices have
not risen a lot
and that way you'll be ready when you'll
feel even better in the summer
and you'll have a place to go i want to
ask you about
what responsibility the tourism the
tourism industry has
related to the pandemic because you know
of course we are seeing this vaccine
roll out very exciting but we're also
seeing cases continue to go
up so what do you think the tourism
industry
needs to do to continue to keep people
safe even as it does feel to some that
the pandemic is coming to a close
well we have been saying from the very
beginning how important safety is and
safety
first beyond everything we want safety
before business and the thing
everybody needs to do is follow the
guidelines that are issued by
authorities like the cdc who now is
saying if you are vaccinated it is safe
to travel
but we always say please wear your mask
where you're supposed to wear a mask
please just follow the distance rules
when you are in places where they ask
you to be distanced
if everybody would just follow the rules
we'd be through this
virus thing so much quicker and i also
want to ask you about one form of travel
that people may
not be missing which is business related
travel i think some folks are
very excited that they've gotten to have
their meetings over zoom companies are
excited that they haven't had to pay for
that but why do you think that consumers
should care
about a lack of business travel moving
forward what impact does that have
you know it's really going to be
interesting because the airlines and the
higher start hotels
made a lot of their profits on business
travel let's face it people in the front
of that plane
at that business uh class seat or the
first class seas
that was a lot of the profits now
without that travel
the economics of the airlines is going
to change and that those big hotels that
cater to business people that can make a
lot of change in terms of service in
terms of frequencies
in terms of how crowded the planes will
be they're going to be some changes
coming you know
i'm concerned that there could be some
more crowded planes as they try
as planes try they try to make profits
by just cramming more people in
and will business travel ever recover
moving forward in your view
well i think eventually the total amount
of business travel will be greater than
2019 just as
our economies around the world grow and
people travel more and more there will
be more business travel
but i think forever it'll be a lower
share of total travel
because people can now do so many types
of communication that
in the past we wouldn't have used so in
the past i would have traveled for a
full day just to have a two-hour meeting
i'm not going to do that anymore i'm
going to do video communication like
we're doing
absolutely well glenn fogle thank you so
much for joining us ceo
of booking.com all right let's get you a
look at some of the day's top
tech headlines it looks like twitter was
in talks to choir clubhouse for
whopping 4 billion sources tell
bloomberg news that talks were held in
recent months
though it's not entirely clear why the
negotiation stalled
earlier this week bloomberg news
reported clubhouse is looking to start a
fundraising round
seeking a four billion dollar valuation
and apple is making it easier to keep
track of some of your things
the company updated its find my service
to locate items from
non-apple manufacturers starting next
week users can find their
van move e-bikes chipolo item trackers
and belkin wireless earbuds using the
find my app on iphones
or any web connected device via icloud
and pinterest is preparing some new
features to keep its community
free of toxic behaviors the social
network is launching its creator code
a content policy with guidelines aimed
at keeping pinterest quote a positive
and inspiring place
creators on pinterest will have to sign
on the creator code
before being able to publish story pins
the creator code will start rolling out
in the next few weeks
for the latest tech news
bookmarkbloomberg.com forward slash
technology
and coming up after the break could the
filibuster's days be numbered we'll talk
to a bloomberg opinion writer about why
the procedure may be fading away
access the financial world on demand
hear from leading economists
policymakers
and industry experts via live and
on-demand webinars
only from bloomberg
start exploring to see what's moving the
markets
visit bloomberg.com webinars
our generation's biggest problem climate
change
is happening and the world's most
innovative solutions
transport industry uh buildings
electricity
all of those things everything you need
to know about our changing environment
the politics of global warming we can
and we will deal with climate change
in the fight against climate change
bloomberg green has you covered
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
president biden is pressing ahead on his
2 trillion dollar infrastructure plan
that's despite opposition from
republicans who are hesitant to commit
to
getting behind the scale of the plan and
the tax increases needed to fund
it but there are increasing signs that
the plan may move ahead despite that
opposition
some democratic party lawmakers are
looking to bring an end to one tool
republicans may look to
to hold up the progress and that tool is
the filibuster
here to tell us more about the possible
future of that tool is bloomberg opinion
writer jonathan bernstein jonathan
thanks so much for being here
president biden has been hesitant to
come out firmly in support of ending the
filibuster but
at the same time we're seeing him push
ahead on the tax hike and
all of these really progressive plans
like tomorrow he's planning to announce
this
gun violence plan what's the likelihood
of the current filibuster process as we
know it coming to an
end before biden has to push through on
these policies
it's not real real likely to end very
soon
um although there's a lot of uncertainty
about that
mainly because right now the democrats
have such a narrow margin in the senate
they only have
you know a 50-50 tie with the vice
president breaking the tie
if there were 52 or 53 democratic
senators right now
the filibuster would basically be dead
do we need to get rid of the filibuster
for or does biden need to get rid of the
filibuster to get these progressive
policies
moving forward well what's happening
because they don't have the votes to get
rid of the filibuster altogether
what's happening is they're pushing
around the margins and we just don't
know
how to what extent senator manchin uh
senator cinema
the more marginal democratic senators
are willing to do that but for example
we've seen already
now that um chuck schumer the democratic
leader
has uh found a new a new wrinkle
in reconciliation procedures which is a
way to get
through the senate without uh being
subject to a filibuster so that
where once upon a time you could do that
once in a congress
then republicans found a way to do it
maybe twice during congress and now
uh senator schumer has found ways to do
it maybe several times per
congress so uh we're look we're moving
in the direction
of perhaps finding little bullet holes
to put
through the filibuster um senator
feinstein today said that she was
willing to
uh vote to get rid of the filibuster
when it came to voting rights
i don't think there's 50 votes yet to do
that but there could be
over the course of this congress what do
you make of the far
left or mid-left's reaction to
biden not coming out firmly against the
filibuster do you think that that's fair
uh you know he's not a senator anymore
he doesn't have a vote
um ultimately this is whether all 50
democratic
senators are going to be for it and you
know
senator joe manchin of west virginia
doesn't have to listen to joe biden he
doesn't have to listen to
um very liberal democrats he has to
listen to
his own feelings about what he wants to
get done what he thinks will help him
for reelection
and so biden is sort of irrelevant to
all this process the main process is
our job joe manchin our center cinema
and other
marginal you know moderately liberal
democrats going to get so frustrated
about not passing things
that they will go ahead and change the
rules so we've talked about the
opposition to the filibuster but is
there an argument for it can you tell me
about
the pros yeah the the case for the
filibuster over time has basically been
that it already gives individual
senators
more influence within the senate than
they would have otherwise then
for example the house everything runs
basically by majority party fiat
uh you know whatever the majority party
says that's what happens in the senate
individual senators have been able to
cut deals
and make bargains over time because
parties have become
more important in american politics
that's become less and less important to
those individual senators so that most
democrats right now
and most republicans when the
republicans have the majority
are very interested in cross-party
coalition they're not interested in
getting their own
individual measures through they're
interested in helping their party
and that's why the filibuster is
probably doomed because
senators individual senators no longer
care very much about
their own personal influence within the
senate i'm going to quickly jonathan ask
you to see the future for me how long do
you think it's going to take for
your vision of what's going to happen to
the filibuster to come to life
certainly the next time we have a
unified government with
a strong with 54 55 56
um senators the majority that will be
the end of it it's possible though it
could end even earlier
all right jonathan bernstein thanks so
much for that now coming up after the
break in a world of big wind is there a
place for tiny turbines
we'll hear more about how some companies
are carving out space for smaller
turbines
in the energy energy industry next
[Music]
access the financial world on demand
hear from leading policy makers
and industry experts via live and
on-demand webinars
only from bloomberg
start exploring to see what's moving the
markets
visit bloomberg.com webinars
[Music]
[Music]
do
small wind turbines have been around for
decades but they've struggled to carve
out a dedicated market space
the tiny equipment has also struggled to
compete with solar for small-scale
applications
but that's all changing now one
australian company is a niche market for
tiny turbines
joining us now to discuss this is
bloomberg news reporter georgie mckay
georgie thanks so much for being here
we just described this niche market but
in your own words
tell me what trends you found in your
reporting about this
sure hi madison so diffuse energy has
developed a tiny turbine
it's about the height of a large
standing fan that's less than three feet
wide and lighter than a pickup
truck tire which is quite uncommon when
the rest of the
largest wind companies in the world are
developing these
crazy big turbines but this company's
our ceo
and co-founder was initially researching
the use of this small wind technology
to power onboard systems of yachts but
he said it was hard to get investors
excited about
giving your owners an extra week or two
of power outages
so the company pivoted when a
telecommunications company became
interested in the product
to attach the uh turbine to the top of
the telecommunications tower
and integrate this product into existing
solar and battery systems
and this uh pivot i suppose to
small wind isn't uncommon it's been done
before there's a start-up
in the uk alpha 311 who is producing a
similar small wind turbine
uh it's extremely light and the company
said it could be picked up by a small
child and this product has been picked
up
by the o2 arena in london to power the
entire stadium which is pretty cool
georgie i think it's fair for us to take
a second to talk about how these are
very cute tiny turbines right
yes for sure and taking a step back you
know it's obviously more important than
the cuteness and smallness here
why should we care about wind turbines
and telecommunication sites what are the
implications
i think the most important part of this
is that
a small wind turbine can replace the
need for diesel
which is obviously great for the
environment and it also can provide
a reliable energy source when i was
speaking to
um the company's co-founder he said that
telecommunications companies in
australia and in other countries as well
the the towers are in these remote areas
and they're often affected by fire and
floods
so by having a diesel generator if you
can't access the site you can't repair
it and then that threatens
people being able to use their phone in
a disaster sort of situation
so by installing a small wind turbine
you can
effectively ensure that there is power
around the clock when a natural disaster
strikes
right when i was reading your story i
was reminded of the texas power grid
failure
that we had in the us following you know
huge snowstorm
is this one way that we could
potentially avoid events like that in
the future
um i suppose so yes it's it's perfect
for
these remote sites and for i think
the best part about this technology is
that it can be applied to
such a niche situations and it can
off-grid power supply could be a good
example of where this small scale
turbine
might work so you can put it in a remote
mine side you can put it in the forest
on a telco
tower you can give it to a village
that's
far away from the grid the company
mentioned in indonesia where
there's it's very difficult to access a
centralized power grid just because of
the geography the
the country is made up of some 17 000
islands
so in in this case this product perfect
when
they're not traditional geography and
power
availability and this comes even as the
world is looking to build the biggest
turbines ever so is there a place for
small turbines absolutely i don't think
these companies both the fuse and alpha
311 they aren't trying to replace
power um stations they're never going to
be able to offer that
extremely large power supply but
they can support these niche situations
such as powering telco sites or powering
the o2 arena or some other things that i
mentioned
off the grid mine sites and everything
so when it's applied and the geography
is perfect for these
um for this technology to thrive then
yes it does have a place
but um not on a large scale as large
as these massive turbines we're seeing
or possibly even
solar because solar is still just so
much deeper
all right georgie mckay thanks so much
for joining us and that does it for
quick take this hour you can check out
the latest stories
at bloomberg.com or at quicktake on
social media have a good night everyone
[Music]
[Music]
access the financial world on demand
hear from leading economists
policymakers
and industry experts via live and
on-demand webinars
only from bloomberg
start exploring to see what's moving the
markets
visit bloomberg.com webinars
[Music]
our generation's biggest problem climate
change
is happening and the world's most
innovative solutions
transport industry uh buildings
electricity
all of those things everything you need
to know about our changing environment
the politics of global warming we can
and we will deal with climate change in
the fight against climate change
bloomberg green has you covered
[Music]
coming up on quick take the lead a new
warning from the uk
on the heavily debated astrazeneca
vaccine
healthy people under 30 are being
offered an alternative shot
what we know about evidence of rare
blood clots associated with the jab
then with summer approaching and more
people getting vaccinated a lot of us
are really excited to travel again
we'll speak to the ceo of the largest
online travel company to find out where
americans are most eager to go next and
a possible political game changer to
keep president biden's two
trillion dollar infrastructure package
on track
we'll tell you what you need to know
about the important u.s filibuster
it's wednesday april 7th i'm madison
mills those stories and more coming up
on quicktake the lead
we start today with news of the
embattled astrazeneca covet 19 vaccine
eu pharmaceutical regulators announce a
possible link between the shot and blood
clots although they do claim that it's
very rare
questions about the shot's safety have
emerged in recent weeks
and several european countries briefly
suspended their use of the vaccine
last month now the uk joint committee on
vaccination and immunization
has decided it's safer to advise people
aged 18 to 29
to get a different shot whenever
possible they still contend that the
overall benefits of the astrazeneca shot
far outweigh the risks in some cases
there is still
a benefit to younger people from
being vaccinated and overall that
benefit
is still in favor of being vaccinated
it happens that where we have an
alternative vaccine
we feel on balance it would be
preferable
to offer the very youngest people who
have no other health conditions
the alternative vaccine instead of the
estrogenical vaccine
to help make sense of these findings
we're joined by dr susannah hills from
columbia university medical center dr
hills thanks so much for being here
i'm hoping to get some clarity from you
because i certainly didn't get it from
today's
presser we're hearing that the shot is
potentially causing clots but it's also
unlikely but also don't take it if
you're too young it's a little bit of
whiplash here
so what was your takeaway from today's
astrazeneca news
right i think that the punch line
um of today's news really is that
this vaccine is still incredibly safe
we just have to keep it in perspective
um
the vaccine has been shown to be 75
effective in preventing symptomatic
covaid it's nearly 100 effective
in preventing hospitalizations and
deaths from coping 19.
so those are incredible results and the
benefits here really
outweigh the very tiny risk
that they're talking about which are
these brain clots they've given about 25
million doses
of this vaccine and they've had i think
64 cases
of clots in the brain and an additional
28 in the abdomen i believe so the
numbers of the clots are just
so so low right um and the benefit is
really outweighing the risk here i think
right and i want to dig into another
number associated with what you just
mentioned doctor which is that the mhra
said today that the clotting is very
rare but they gathered
some data that they presented
specifically regarding young people that
i want to point out they
basically said that the risk is just a
little bit more present for
younger younger individuals that the
risk of clots is four in a million
that number sounds low so do you think
that there's a chance that we
freaked out a little prematurely here
and might discourage
younger people from even getting their
shots
that's the concern right um
every as we're learning more and more
about this disease and about the
vaccines that can help prevent it
we have to you know take things in
perspective
and and you know take the long view um
so we are going to learn more as we get
more information
guidelines are going to change and it's
going to require people to be a little
bit flexible in the guidance that's
given
but this kind of low low low incidence
of this complication
really in terms of the other things that
we recommend like
you know a daily aspirin for example um
for
preventing you know complications of
heart attacks i mean about
you know two and a thousand people are
going to have a
significant stroke or brain bleed
related to that
that's a much higher risk and yet
because it saves lives we still
recommend it all the time
so if we try to keep things in
perspective i think you know looking at
the you know over 550 000 people that
have died
over 30 million cases and the clear
benefit
of this vaccine that can you know really
keep almost 100
percent of people out of the hospital um
that's that's the thing to focus on
and i feel like i'm getting more clarity
from you than i did in these
pressers today i'm curious about you
know in the uk they said that if you're
30 or if you're 31 if you're on that
line you're just gonna have to make the
decision yourself it's really up to you
what's behind this lack of clarity here
are regulators just
afraid that they might um you know say
something they have to go back on later
or
why why is there such vagueness right
now
yeah yeah well i think we have business
right now because we just don't have the
data
to fully answer these questions um the
clinical trials that were done weren't
designed to look at these risks in an
age stratified sense
so you know looking at complications in
30 versus 31 versus 50
they weren't really designed that way
and
when the the study populations in the
original clinical trials
were were relatively although they
contained tens of thousands of people
relatively small right
so when you're talking about a hand you
know a handful in
25 million vaccine doses administered of
having clots
you're not going to pick up enough cases
of clots in the populations that were
measured in the first clinical trials
that were really truly rigorous trials
with rigorous answers
so the best they can do right now is
share information and
and then you know give more concrete
guidance as we have more data
dr hills in our final minute here
pregnant people and children what should
they be thinking about the astro shot
yeah i you know it's natural for
everybody to take their own personal
medical history and
you know take that into account people
who have
i think we might be losing dr hills oh
you're back okay i'm sorry go ahead
sorry about that yeah so you know
pregnant women have an increased risk
of clotting people of clotting disorders
may think about this vaccine differently
but even still when you're talking about
this low
of a number of cases of this happening
i still would say this vaccine is
incredibly safe i think it's important
to relay that message because we need
this vaccine
and we need people to feel comfortable
taking it and we have
every reason to think it's still going
to be safe and extremely effective
dr hills really appreciate you joining
us and clearing that up thank you so
much
now let's get you some other coronavirus
headlines from around the world
the international monetary fund says
governments should consider a wealth tax
to help cover the costs of the pandemic
as inequality has widened due to the
virus the imf is making the case that
those better off
should be asked to pay more on a
temporary basis in an interview with
bloomberg's tom keane
imf managing director kristelina
georgiva said the vaccines
also play a big role we provide
clear and compelling case for
accelerating vaccinations everywhere
the world economy is going to be 9
trillion dollars richer between now
and 2025 if vaccinations
are accelerated and if countries like
brazil
and india are in a position to do
more to get out of the health crisis
and according to the first large-scale
research on the coronavirus
one in three people who were severely
ill with covid
were subsequently diagnosed with a
neurological or psychiatric condition
the university of oxford study found
that anxiety was the most
common condition to develop six months
after getting infected with the virus
while researchers found no specific
causes of these long-term effects
they suggest it could be linked to
stress job losses or even loneliness
and beijing is putting up color-coded
signs on buildings that indicate
what percentage of workers inside have
been vaccinated
the city's financial district is leading
the campaign to green code its buildings
locations get a green circular sign if
over 80 percent of those working inside
have gotten their shots
government officials say the move is
aimed at accelerating the vaccine
rollout
now for the latest covent news
bookmarkbloomberg.com forward slash
coronavirus
and coming up after the break the u.s
economy will boom into 2023
but inequality needs to be addressed we
break down key points from jpmorgan ceo
jamie dimon's annual letter of
shareholders
stay with us
[Music]
[Music]
access the financial world on demand
[Music]
hear from leading economists
policymakers
and industry experts via live and
on-demand webinars
only from bloomberg
start exploring to see what's moving the
markets
visit bloomberg.com webinars
our generation's biggest problem climate
change
is happening and the world's most
innovative solutions
transport industry uh buildings
electricity
all of those things everything you need
to know about our changing environment
the politics of global warming we can
and we will deal with climate change
in the fight against climate change
bloomberg green has you covered
[Music]
[Music]
jamie dimon who built one of the most
profitable banks in u.s history
is sounding the alarm on the future of
american prosperity
in an annual letter to shareholders the
jp morgan ceo
said that the pandemic and the murder of
george floyd have exposed
long-standing and profound inequities
diamond wrote quote
many of our citizens are unsettled and
the fault line for all of this discord
is fraying the american dream
the enormous wealth in this country is
accruing to the very few
his letter comes as companies and
business leaders face pressure to take a
stand on important social issues ranging
from voting rights to racism and
inequality as a whole so joining us now
to discuss is bloomberg banking reporter
hannah levitt hannah thanks for being
here
first off i want to take a big step back
for those who aren't familiar
who is jamie dimon and what is he
staying saying about the state of
inequality in the u.s here yeah so thank
you for having me
um jamie dimon is the ceo of jpmorgan
which is the biggest u.s bank
um and additionally it's one of the
biggest biggest companies
in the country um and it has a huge you
know employee base
um and he's also been around a long time
he's been ceo of jp morgan since the end
of 2005.
um so today he put out his annual
shareholder letter and this is something
he does every year
um this year's was the longest yet it
was 66 pages
um and you know one one of the biggest
issues that he hit on was just lamenting
the inequality um in
in this country and the effects of you
know
like you said the pandemic and the
murder of george floyd and in
the role that those played exposing that
so besides the crowd of bankers who are
going to be
interested in reading this why does it
matter what diamond has to say what's
the potential impact here
yeah so look jamie diamond is incredibly
influential as a business curtain
person he's very influential uh around
the world and
within the us and if you think about you
know he's kind of a spokesperson for the
banking industry um
and a lot of a lot of banks specifically
tend to follow what what jp morgan says
and what jamie dimon says
uh so he really he wields that influence
you know across the country and he's not
new to kind of influencing these
cultural
social justice conversations he's made
these comments for quite some time now
what was surprising to you about the
comments in this 66 66-page letter
uh that came out today yeah that's
correct
um what stood out to me was just the the
amount of space dedicated
to these issues and uh really making the
economic case for fixing them which he's
done
before but 66 pages is very long
um and so we saw a lot of that today
what did you make of the length of the
letter why why did it need to be
that long um i think because 2020 was a
long year right
right fair enough fair enough uh that
definitely makes sense given 2020.
i do want to talk a little bit about the
flip side of this which
you know what comes to mind is his taxes
in 2020
his annual salary was 31.5 million
dollars and
you know he's he's talking about wealth
inequality uh
what's his position on how his own
wealth pay plays into income inequality
as a whole
yeah so jamie dimon is a billionaire and
that's important to note we've
seen the the backlash against
billionaires for years um
but he he's advocated for
a lower a competitive corporate tax
which means lower
um but he seems to be okay with taxing
the wealthy like him more um and that
you know he said in his letter today
that wealthy people should keep in mind
that
if their tax dollars go to better you
know society and the economy that they
ultimately benefit as well and diamonds
comments come in the wave of
corporations and ceos speaking out about
social justice issues we're seeing all
of these ceos speaking out about voting
rights restrictions in the state of
georgia for example
i'm curious are these comments from
diamond uh just
good pr because this is expected of ceos
right now or is this
genuine yeah so look um i think there
are multiple factors at play here first
of all
jamie dimon and jp morgan have a lot of
people
dedicated to you know staying in tune
with this stuff whether it be
people in like pr people or lobbyist
people in washington etc
um but at the same time i mean he's
always been
outspoken um and so
yeah of course i mean of course
corporations can do more we've seen
we've seen them
uh step up a bit in the past year but of
course there's always room to do more
but at the same time
diamond seems to um you know he makes an
economic case for it
uh which i think is worth noting and
he's talked about running for president
before do you think that this had any
political ambition behind it
or was it again was it genuine yeah look
so there's there's been speculation um
every cycle uh and as these annual
letters have
which he's been doing these forever but
they've gotten longer and dedicating
more space
um but he's he's shut that down so yeah
fair enough bloomberg's hannah lovett
thank you so much for joining us
appreciate it
all right in minneapolis the trial of
derek chauvin did continue today
the jury heard from jody steiger a los
angeles police department sergeant and
use of force expert
steiger said that chauvin never took his
knee off george floyd's neck
from the time officers put him on the
ground until paramedics arrived
and you tell the jury at what point in
time in your opinion does the restraint
itself begin based on my review of the
body worn video
the restraint started at
20 19 and 14 seconds
and when does the restraint period end
i believe it was 20 28 and 43 seconds
and sir what is the duration then of
that time period the restraint period
nine minutes and 29 seconds
steiger's testimony came a day after
chauvin's attorney eric nelson
sought to point out moments in the video
footage when he said
chauvin's knee did not appear to be on
floyd's neck
chauvin is charged with murder and
manslaughter in floyd's death
last may and in other news from around
the world an iranian ship believed to be
a base for the paramilitary
revolutionary guard has been attacked in
the red sea
that's according to the country's local
government local officials suspect the
attack was carried out by
israel the assault came as iran and
several world powers met in vienna to
try and resurrect the tattered nuclear
deal
some experts do say the ship which has
been anchored in the red sea for years
has provided arms and support to yemen's
houthi rebels
iran has previously described the vessel
as aiding in anti-piracy efforts
and in turkey a visit from two top
european officials is igniting
conversation over
gender equality tv images show only two
chairs were available when president
erdogan met with ursula vonderlein and
charles michelle
as michelle took the seat next to
erdogan vonderlein was left standing
and eventually took the seat of a second
rank official on a nearby couch
brussels had this to say about the
incident the president
should have been seated exactly in the
same manner
as the president of the european council
and the
and the turkish president
but as i said she decided to proceed
nevertheless
prioritizing substance over protocol
and rwandan president paul gagami is
praising a french report
documenting france's role in the 1994
genocide
he says the rwandan government
interpreted the report as
saying france knew that a genocide
against the tutsis
was being planned by their rwandi's
allies but continued to support them
france says its report clears it of
complicity in the massacres
this week marks the anniversary of the
beginning of the genocide that left
nearly 1 million people dead for the
latest news from your part of the world
go to bloomberg.com click on the
addition drop down right next to the
bloomberg masthead and choose your
region
and staying in africa jihadists in
mozambique forced the french energy firm
total
to suspend work at its multi-billion
dollar liquefied
natural gas project in the country next
up quick takes mark daniel davies
explains the conflict's origin and what
it could mean for southern africa's
economic development
this 20 billion dollar natural gas
project in northern mozambique
is the single biggest private investment
in africa
the government here hopes to reap as
much as 100 billion dollars in revenue
over the next 25 years
that's more than six times the country's
annual gdp
but what's meant to be a gas bonanza for
one of the world's poorest countries
is developing alongside a deadly
insurgency
i'm mark davies for bloomberg quick take
here's what you need to know
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
since 2017 more than 2 600 people have
died
and 700 thousand displaced as violent
attacks spread in the cabo delgado
province
in march dozens of people were killed in
a raid by islamist militants
just a few miles from the project site
french gas giant total in response
halted operations on its 20 billion
venture for a second time in 2021
they have done horrific things they are
still doing so they had seen bodies
laying on the streets
thousands are making their way by foot
boat and road
some are being rescued by the un's
humanitarian air services
evidence suggests insurgents in
mozambique's north began as an islamist
sect in 2007. by the mid-2010s it had
shifted to
armed jihadism the group carrying out
attacks in the capital guard
is known as al-shabab al-shabab just
means a day off
in arab there is no known non-leakage
with the group with the same name
operating in somalia the first attack
happened in 2017
but the group activity in terms of
radicalization
can be trusted five years before i think
that much of this
really has to do with smuggling
syndicates
that have been operating for decades for
generations in the area this is a really
rural
marginalized area and they they
therefore serve as very
fertile ground for for recruitment and
the only source
in a sense of employment of opportunity
is through smuggling networks and
through
radicals that offer them some payment
and some money
and it seems like the smugglers are
partly attempting to protect
their smuggling roots and and building
on
local frustrations about the potential
mass
gas exploration that is developing are
able to recruit locals
[Music]
mozambique's army has struggled to
contain the violence so
far it's brought in russian and south
african private military companies to
quell attacks
with very little success more recently
the state has started social programs
targeting vulnerable young people
this in hopes of addressing discontent
over a lack of jobs and opportunities
but for now the conflict continues
the results are very poor even with this
assistance from property military
company this group manages to attack and
occupy
five district headquarters so five towns
that is huge in less than a year
mozambique fought a civil war 16-year
civil war
and did not see such such a situation of
attacking the occupying district towns
like what is happening here
the region and regional governments like
south africa have long been aware of the
emerging problem
but the government in maputo like most
governments have said
guys this is a national problem uh we
will deal with this
nationally there's a lot that southern
africa
the africa union and the international
community can do
but eventually um it's all dependent
upon the
world and the capacity of the government
in maputo this is their territory and
and law and order and combating this
insurgency primarily lies there
coming up after the break vaccines are
helping the u.s bounce back from the
pandemic
but how can we get vaccines to
marginalized communities
more when we come back
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so
[Music]
access the financial world on demand
[Music]
hear from leading economists
policymakers
and industry experts via live and
on-demand webinars
only from bloomberg
start exploring to see what's moving the
markets
visit bloomberg.com webinars
[Music]
[Music]
for some people in the u.s pre-pandemic
life feels closer than ever because of
the increasingly speedy
vaccine rollout but one harsh reality is
that marginalized communities are not
getting equal access to the shots
quick takes matthew albany spoke with
city lab sarah holder about one solution
to fight that
sarah thanks for joining us so we've
seen a lot of milestones in the u.s when
it comes to the vaccine rollout
but obviously there's still a lot of
work that needs to be done
where is the country standing right now
thanks for having me um yeah in the u.s
the vaccine roller has been
accelerating in the past few weeks
according to bloomberg's vaccine tracker
169 million doses have been given so far
in the u.s that's an average of
3 million doses a day in the past week
an
eligibility requirements are loosening
in many states you know uh people 16 and
up
uh will be able to get the vaccine in
many states um
by mid april including in california um
meanwhile of course there are also
variants of concern that are spreading
around the country and public health
experts have warned that
if we don't get those under control by
the time that we
get more of the population vaccinated
there could be the potential for
a fourth wave but people are hoping that
a vaccine rollout will
continue um to accelerate uh to
defend that wave off right and that's
one of the things that i wanted to bring
up when it comes to the conversation of
vaccine roll out there's been
a lot of conversation about it going
towards
mainly affluent areas and
based on your piece i wanted to talk
about what are some of the barriers that
people are having when it comes to
accessing this
and you know are there any strategies
that are being implemented to help
educate people
and also help the vaccines you know help
people get the vaccines that they need
absolutely i mean you mentioned the
geographic and the income disparities in
the rollout you know
in some states you can really see the
disparity
county to county that richer counties
are getting vaccines
faster than poorer counties or that even
within
cities you know different zip codes are
more vaccinated than others so i've
specifically reported on mobile
vaccination units
um so in many counties especially in
northern california but there are few
across the country these are sort of
roving teams of emts and nurses who can
go into these
you know low-income senior housing or
shelter systems
and bring vaccines to folks who can't
make the trek or make an appointment
themselves
and also they've been deploying vaccine
vans
and mobile vaccine vans in some cases so
outside of the big
you know javits center moscone center
these are roving vans that can park in
parking lots and zip codes that again
uh perhaps were harder hit underserved
have high populations of hispanic
residents to black residents
and really target the the people who
haven't yet been targeted
in a concerted enough way and so
i'm really fascinated by you know the
idea of these mobile vaccine units
what does a typical day look like for
them and
you know what are their goals
specifically when it comes to reaching
these communities
yeah so i spent a couple of days with a
mobile vaccination van and a mobile
vaccination unit in marin county which
is in
northern california just across the
golden gate bridge from san francisco
where i'm based
and the mobile vaccine unit as i
mentioned has nurses and emts they
come into a facility with a cooler of
vaccines um the day that i was following
them they used
johnson and johnson so that's one shot
and then you're good to go
um they started at 8 30 in the morning
they set up in this low-income senior
housing facility
got their tables and their syringes set
up and and started
going through people who had either
signed up to get
an appointment based on outreach from
their facility staff
or people who just walked in they were
also vaccinating
staff members who interact with these
older
residents on the daily and
then you know doing what you would see
in some of these centralized facilities
except
right in these people's you know
backyards basically
and for some people who were homebound
who couldn't even leave their apartments
to get recreation room where these
vaccinations are happening
nurses would go into their apartments
and give them a shot right in their
on their couch or in their chairs
um so this truly was really reaching the
people
you know the most vulnerable of the most
vulnerable the people who couldn't find
another way
you know among the nurses and the emts
too there's a sense that it's
that it's you know great to be a part of
um a strategy like this and to really be
reaching out to
to people where they are um and in marin
county for example
but it is a really unequal place and and
um so this is a really concerted effort
again to
bridge those gaps and shrink those
disparities and
so far i think the mobile outreach teams
which are like the mobile units i'm
talking about and the
van that parks and in parking lots
across the county um have
have done thousands and thousands of
jobs about 8 000 shots
um so far and they're you know going to
new places every single day
all right bloomberg city lab sarah
holder thank you so much for giving us
some perspective on
a unique solution that's really seeming
to pay off
thank you so much
quick thanks matthew albany thanks so
much for that report
all right now for today's movers and
shakers the people impacting the world
of business politics and sports
representative matt gates reportedly
asked the white house for blanket
pre-emptive pardons last year
that request was made during the final
weeks of donald trump's turn
according to the nyt the florida
republican's push for a pardon coincided
with the justice department
starting its investigation into sex
trafficking allegations
against him gates says he's innocent and
denied that her pardon request was
related to the investigation
new york governor andrew cuomo says
newly announced tax hikes on the state's
wealthy
could be significantly offset if there's
a repeal of the federal cap on state and
local tax deductions
cuomo says he's spoken to president
biden and fully expects the current 10
000
cap implemented by former president
trump to get repealed
he says that will lower net taxes by
more than 30 percent
and john wilson apparent accused in the
college admissions scandal who is
currently awaiting trial
is suing netflix for defamation
according to wilson's lawyers
the streaming giant's portrayal of
wilson in a new documentary about
operation varsity blues could lead to an
unfair trial
wilson also alleges that the movie
defamed him netflix did not respond to
requests for comment
and those are your movers and shakers
for today
now still ahead we'll tell you about
surprising new research
shining a light on just how eager
americans are to travel again
stick with us
our generation's biggest problem climate
change
is happening and the world's most
innovative solutions
transport industry uh buildings
electricity all of those things
everything you need to know about our
changing environment the politics of
global warming
we can and we will deal with climate
change in the fight against climate
change
bloomberg green has you covered
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
access the financial world on demand
[Music]
hear from leading economists
policymakers
and industry experts via live and
on-demand webinars
only from bloomberg
start exploring to see what's moving the
markets
visit bloomberg.com webinars
[Music]
all right the number of americans
traveling through airports hit another
pandemic high today
as the vaccine rollout is getting more
people excited to travel
on average daily passenger numbers
exceeded 1.4 million last week
which is about 35 below pre-pandemic
levels from the start of 2020
but despite leisure travel rebounding
our next guest says business travel may
actually never recover to those same
levels glenn fogle is ceo of booking
holdings whose subsidiaries include
booking.com
priceline and kayak glenn thank you so
much for joining us
your company commissioned some really
interesting research on how
people plan to travel so glenn before we
get into that
first i just want to know what is the
number one place on your travel bucket
list where are you going first
well first place i have to go when it's
open i need to go to
europe and thank you so much for having
me because travel right now everybody
wants to go
i want to go but amsterdam is for our
headquarters for booking.com
and i haven't seen those people now for
over a year so i've got to get over
there
absolutely europe is definitely on the
list and we're all watching the clock
waiting for the opportunity to be able
to safely travel again
i want to dig into a couple of numbers
here from your
reporting and your research on travel
and how excited people are for it
71 of americans are eager to travel
because of vaccines
61 say they've realized travel is
critical to their emotional well-being
and 60 say travel is more important now
than before the pandemic
started so that's just you know a couple
of data points but i know you've got a
lot more what's
one data point that really sticks out to
you and highlights
just how much people want to be
traveling again you know that issue
people wanting to travel more than
finding a romantic partner is just
remarkable to me
i guess maybe the travel doesn't talk
back to you doesn't argue with you
and it gives you great pleasure no
matter what maybe that's what's going on
there but
look there's a lot of interesting
statistics but you don't need statistics
to know
people want to get going and we want to
help people travel and that's why
we have an incredible promotion right
now if you go to the booking.com app
and you pick a place and you stay we're
going to give you a 50
credit to do it again because we know
everybody wants to travel
but we know from those numbers you just
gave out the numbers are still below
where they were in 2019
we've got to get this industry back and
up and running one way to do it give
people
credit to get them going are you
concerned at all that
despite these findings from your
reporting that you know people
are still reticent to travel then
they're just not feeling fully safe
doing it yet
well i think that people are feeling
safer and safer as things come along and
as more and more people get their
vaccination they feel safer
we see that from the statistics too so
we know as the rollout continues people
are going to feel safer
and plan now get that uh vacation now
blocked up book it while the prices have
not risen a lot
and that way you'll be ready when you'll
feel even better in the summer
and you'll have a place to go i want to
ask you about
what responsibility the tourism the
tourism industry has
related to the pandemic because you know
of course we are seeing this vaccine
roll out very exciting but we're also
seeing cases continue to go up
so what do you think the tourism
industry
needs to do to continue to keep people
safe even as it does feel to some that
the pandemic is coming to a close
well we have been saying from the very
beginning how important safety is and
safety
first beyond everything we want safety
before business and the thing
everybody needs to do is follow the
guidelines that are issued by
authorities like the cdc
who now is saying if you are vaccinated
it is safe to travel
but we always say please wear your mask
where you're supposed to wear a mask
please just follow the distance rules
when you are in places where they ask
you to be distanced
if everybody would just follow the rules
we'd be through this
virus thing so much quicker and i also
want to ask you about one form of travel
that people
may not be missing which is business
related travel i think some folks are
very excited that they've gotten to have
their meetings over zoom companies are
excited that they haven't had to pay for
that
but why do you think that consumers
should care
about a lack of business travel moving
forward what impact does that have
you know it's really going to be
interesting because the airlines and the
higher start hotels
made a lot of their profits on business
travel let's face it people in the front
of that plane
at that business uh class seat or the
first class east
that was a lot of the profits now
without that travel
the economics of the airlines is going
to change and that those big hotels that
cater to business people that can make a
lot of change in terms of service in
terms of frequencies in terms of how
crowded the planes will be
they're going to be some changes coming
you know i i'm concerned that there
could be some
more crowded planes as they try as
planes try they try to make profits by
just cramming more people in
and will business travel ever recover
moving forward in your view
well i think eventually the total amount
of business travel will be greater than
2019 just as our economies around the
world grow and people travel more and
more there will be more business travel
but i think forever it'll be a lower
share of total travel
because people can now do so many types
of communication that
in the past we wouldn't have used so in
the past i would have traveled for a
full day just to have a two-hour meeting
i'm not going to do that anymore i'm
going to do video communication like
we're doing
absolutely well glenn fogle thank you so
much for joining us ceo
of booking.com all right let's get you a
look at some of the day's top
tech headlines it looks like twitter was
in talks to choir clubhouse for a
whopping
4 billion sources tell bloomberg news
that talks were held in recent months
though it's not entirely clear why the
negotiations stalled
earlier this week bloomberg news
reported clubhouse is looking to start a
fundraising round
seeking a 4 billion valuation
and apple is making it easier to keep
track of some of your things
the company updated its find my service
to locate items from non-apple
manufacturers
starting next week users can find their
van move ebikes
chipolo item trackers and belkin
wireless earbuds using the find my app
on
iphones or any web connected device via
icloud
and pinterest is preparing some new
features to keep its community
free of toxic behaviors the social
network is launching its creator code
a content policy with guidelines aimed
at keeping pinterest quote a positive
and inspiring place
creators on pinterest will have to sign
on the creator code
before being able to publish story pins
the creator code will start rolling out
in the next few weeks
for the latest tech news
bookmarkbloomberg.com forward slash
technology
and coming up after the break could the
filibuster's days be numbered
we'll talk to a bloomberg opinion writer
about why the procedure may be fading
away
access the financial world on demand
hear from leading economists
policymakers
and industry experts via live and
on-demand webinars
only from bloomberg
start exploring to see what's moving the
markets
visit bloomberg.com webinars
our generation's biggest problem climate
change
is happening and the world's most
innovative solutions
transport industry buildings electricity
all of those things everything you need
to know about our changing environment
the politics of global warming we can
and we will deal with climate change
in the fight against climate change
bloomberg green has you covered
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
president biden is pressing ahead on his
two trillion dollar infrastructure plan
that's despite opposition from
republicans who are hesitant to commit
to
getting behind the scale of the plan and
the tax increases needed to fund it
but there are increasing signs that the
plan may move ahead despite that
opposition
some democratic party lawmakers are
looking to bring an end to one tool
republicans
may look to to hold up the progress and
that tool
is the filibuster here to tell us more
about the possible
future of that tool is bloomberg opinion
writer jonathan bernstein jonathan
thanks so much for being here
president biden has been hesitant to
come out firmly in support of
ending the filibuster but at the same
time we're seeing him push ahead on the
tax hike and
all of these really progressive plans
like tomorrow he's planning to announce
this
gun violence plan what's the likelihood
of the current filibuster process as we
know it coming to an end
before biden has to push through on
these policies
it's not real real likely to end very
soon
um although there's a lot of uncertainty
about that
mainly because right now the democrats
have such a narrow margin in the senate
they only have
you know a 50-50 tie with the vice
president breaking the tie
if there were 52 or 53 democratic
senators right now
the filibuster would basically be dead
do we need to get rid of the filibuster
for or does biden need to get rid of the
filibuster to get these progressive
policies
moving forward well what's happening
because they don't have the votes to get
rid of the filibuster altogether
what's happening is they're pushing
around the margins and we just don't
know
how to what extent senator manchin
uh senator cinema the more marginal
democratic senators are willing to do
that but for example we've seen already
now that um chuck schumer the democratic
leader
has uh found a a new
wrinkle in reconciliation procedures
which is a way to get
through the senate without uh being
subject to a filibuster so that
where once upon a time you could do that
once in a congress
then republicans found a way to do it
maybe twice during congress and now
uh senator schumer has found ways to do
it maybe several times per congress
so we're look we're moving in the
direction of
perhaps finding little bullet holes to
put
through the filibuster um senator
feinstein today
said that she was willing to uh vote to
get rid of the filibuster when it came
to voting rights
i don't think there's 50 votes yet to do
that but there could be
over the course of this congress what do
you make of the far
left or mid-left's reaction to biden not
coming out firmly against the filibuster
do you think that that's fair
uh you know he's not a senator anymore
he don't have a vote
um ultimately this is whether all 50
democratic senators are going to be for
it
and you know senator joe manchin of west
virginia
doesn't have to listen to joe biden he
doesn't have to listen to
um very liberal democrats he has to
listen to
his own feelings about what he wants to
get on what he thinks will help him for
reelection
and so biden is sort of irrelevant to
all this process the main process is
our job joe manchin are senator cinema
and other marginal you know moderately
liberal democrats going to get so
frustrated about not passing things
that they will go ahead and change the
rules so we've talked about the
opposition to the filibuster but is
there an argument for it can you tell me
about the pros
yeah the the case for the filibuster
over time has basically been
that it already it gives individual
senators
more influence within the senate then
they would have otherwise been
for example the house everything runs
basically by majority party fiat
uh you know whatever the majority party
says that's what happens in the senate
individual senators have been able to
cut deals and make bargains
over time because parties have become
more important in american politics
that's become less and less important to
those individual senators so that
most democrats right now and most
republicans when the republicans have
the majority
are very interested in cross-party
coalition they're not interested in
getting their own
individual measures through their
interest in helping their party
and that's why the filibuster is
probably doomed because
senators individual senators no longer
care very much about
their own personal influence within the
senate i'm going to quickly jonathan ask
you to see the future for me how long do
you think it's going to take for
your vision of what's going to happen to
the filibuster to come to life
certainly the next time we have a
unified government
with a strong with 54 55 56
um senators the majority that will be
the end of it it's possible though it
could end even earlier
all right jonathan bernstein thanks so
much for that now coming up after the
break in a world of big wind
is there a place for tiny turbines we'll
hear more about how some companies are
carving out space for smaller turbines
in the energy energy industry next
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
access the financial world on demand
[Music]
hear from leading economists
policymakers
and industry experts via live and
on-demand webinars
only from bloomberg
start exploring to see what's moving the
markets
visit bloomberg.com webinars
[Music]
[Music]
small wind turbines have been around for
decades but they've struggled to carve
out a dedicated market space
the tiny equipment has also struggled to
compete with solar for small-scale
applications
but that's all changing now one
australian company is a niche market for
tiny turbines
joining us now to discuss this is
bloomberg news reporter georgie mckay
georgie thanks so much for being here
we just described this niche market but
in your own words
tell me what trends you found in your
reporting about this
sure hi madison so diffuse energy has
developed a tiny turbine it's about the
height of a large standing fan
that's less than three feet wide and
lighter than a pickup truck tire
which is quite uncommon when the rest of
the largest
wind companies in the world are
developing these crazy big turbines
but this company's our ceo and
co-founder was initially researching the
use of this small wind technology
to power onboard systems of yachts but
he said it was hard to get investors
excited about
giving your owners an extra week or two
of power outage
so the company pivoted when a
telecommunications company became
interested in the product
to attach the uh turbine to the top of a
telecommunications
tower and integrate this product into
existing solar and battery systems
and this pivot i suppose to
small wind isn't uncommon it's been done
before there's a start-up um in the uk
alpha 311 who is producing a similar
small wind turbine
uh it's extremely light and the company
said it could be picked up by a small
child and this product has been picked
up
by the o2 arena in london to power the
entire stadium which is pretty cool
georgie i think it's fair for us to take
a second to talk about how these are
very cute tiny turbines right
yes for sure and taking a step back you
know it's obviously more important than
the cuteness and smallness here
why should we care about wind turbines
and telecommunication sites what are the
implications
i think the most important part of this
is that
a small wind turbine can replace the
need for diesel
which is obviously great for the
environment and it also can provide
a reliable energy source when i was
speaking to
um the company's co-founder he said that
telecommunications companies in
australia and in other countries as well
the the towers are in these remote areas
and they're often affected by fire and
floods
so by having a diesel generator if you
can't access the site
you can't repair it and then that
threatens uh people being able to use
their phone in a disaster sort of
situation
so by installing a small wind turbine
you can
effectively ensure that there is power
around the clock when a natural disaster
strikes
right when i was reading your story i
was reminded of the texas power grid
failure
that we had in the u.s following you
know huge snowstorm
is this one way that we could
potentially avoid events like that in
the future
um i suppose so yes it's it's perfect
for
these remote sites and for i think
the best part about this technology is
that it can be applied to
certain niche situations and it can
off-grid power supply could be a good
example of where this small scale
turbine
might work so you can put it in a remote
mine side you can put it in the forest
on a telco tower you can give it to
a village that's far away from the grid
the company mentioned in indonesia where
there's it's very difficult to access a
centralized power grid just because of
the geography the
the country is made up of some 17 000
islands
so in in this case this product perfect
when
they're not traditional geography and
power
availability and this comes even as the
world is looking to build the biggest
turbines ever so is there a place
for small turbines absolutely i don't
think
these companies both the fuse and alpha
3-1-1 they aren't trying to replace
power stations they're never going to be
able to offer that
extremely large power supply but
they can support these niche situations
such as powering telco sites or powering
the o2 arena or some other things that i
mentioned
off the grid mine sites and everything
so when it's applied and the geography
is perfect for these
um for this technology to thrive then
yes it does have a place
but um not on a large scale as large as
these massive turbines we're seeing or
possibly even
solar because solar is still just so
much deeper
all right georgie mckay thanks so much
for joining us and that does it for
quick take this hour you can check out
the latest stories at bloomberg.com or
at quick take on social media
have a good night everyone
[Music]
[Music]
access the financial world on demand
hear from leading economists
policymakers
and industry experts via live and
on-demand webinars
only from bloomberg
start exploring to see what's moving the
markets
visit bloomberg.com webinars
[Music]
our generation's biggest problem climate
change
is happening and the world's most
innovative solutions
transport industry buildings electricity
all of those things everything you need
to know about our changing environment
the politics of global warming we can
and we will deal with climate change
in the fight against climate change
bloomberg green has you covered
[Music]
i'm kurumi mori in tokyo and this is
quick take geo
[Music]
a plea for international help miss grand
myanmar uses her stage to speak out
against the violence in her home country
we sit down with hanley to hear her
story
going going gone new zealand house
prices are through the roof and home
buyers are feeling the pinch
golf club memberships are going for a
quarter of a million dollars in
singapore as many wait for borders to
reopen
we take you to the green plus a migrant
worker exodus from the uk
we dig deeper into what this means in
the long term
and a community for all you sneakerheads
we meet the couple who built an
online marketplace just for premium
sneakers
when myanmar's representative in the
miss grand international beauty pageant
took the stage
she brought attention to our country's
ongoing democratic struggle in a
head-turning speech
she now remains in thailand afraid to go
home
we caught up with her to hear why she
chose to speak out
the situation in yama is really bad dave
idea
hanley a beauty pageant contestant from
myanmar made international headlines
when she spoke out against the country's
military at the miss grand
international event in thailand
i deeply be sorry for the people who
have lost their life on the streets
every citizen of the world wants the
prosperity
of their country and the peaceful
environment
in doing so the leader involved should
not use their power
and selfishness to apply why do i know
some people
young women and children reach their
life
we need your rj international hub right
now
[Music]
i almost want to cry because of everyone
know that this is very
feeling it's very sad because so many
people say in myanmar so
i decided to to speak out my voice
hundreds of pro-democracy protesters
have been killed in the two months since
the military coup sparked daily street
protests in major cities
and in recent weeks the military has
also stepped up its campaign against the
country's
ethnic groups carrying out deadly
airstrikes that have forced
thousands from their homes this
airstrikes
killed so many cayenne people and i saw
that so many
kenyan children die on the streets so
many people is
high and i think that it is enough to
die because of
we only want the democracy and we only
went back to our leader right now
and they shoot the people everything can
happen in myanmar right now
so i just worry for my family
hanley says she's afraid of the
consequences of speaking out but will
not
back down sure i am a person
i am a woman i afraid for that but just
think about the people from myanmar
they are trying to protest on the
streets and they are in the gangs right
now
the 22 year old didn't take home the
crown in the international beauty
pageant but she hopes to continue to use
her platform to highlight what's
happening in her homeland
i have a platform to speak out i
actually hope that the situation in
myanmar
very end soon because of so many people
time in myanmar and we all want just did
humanity
because we lost our freedom our freedom
are right now from the fear
new zealand is now becoming one of the
least affordable housing markets in the
world and house buyers are feeling the
pinch
it's a brutal process at the moment in
terms of just how many people are going
for it and the fact that there just are
not enough houses out there on the
market and it's driving the prices up
something
astronomical in a way that we just
haven't seen before the last
year or so has cost me somewhere in the
equivalent of about 150 160 grand
just because of how much and how quickly
the house prices are going up
it's it's give or take about 20 grand a
month
joining us for more is bloomberg's
ainslie thompson in wellington
hey ainsley the housing market there
seems really hot right now what's behind
the trend
it's fair to say that things here have
gone pretty crazy
the housing market is very very hot and
there's a lot of concern that we're now
in bubble territory
in the year to february house prices
rose about
20 and auckland is now the fourth least
affordable city in the world
and it's not just auckland it's the
whole country it's also the provincial
centres which is something we haven't
seen in the past
the competition between buyers is
incredibly intense
um at open homes there's queues to get
in and that's just to you know to view
the property that people might want to
buy
at auctions and i've been to a few of
those it's standing room only
and this means that people are putting
in offers you know hundreds of thousands
of dollars above the
the government's rateable value and
sometimes millions of dollars above
the medium house price which is about
780 000
kiwi dollars is now 6.7 times the
average household income
and to be affordable it should be about
three times and
to get down to that affordable level um
house prices would have to fall by about
55 percent
or incomes would have to rise by about
123 percent
wow and how is the government addressing
these sky-high prices
well as you can imagine jacinda dern's
government is under
a huge amount of political pressure to
do something
they've campaigned a lot on addressing
inequality in new zealand and also
addressing the housing crisis
but so far in their time in government
they haven't really managed to have much
impact on that this year though they've
definitely
are trying a bit harder they've um
they've put part of the responsibility
onto the reserve bank
they now have to take housing the
housing market into account when they're
sitting monetary policy
they have tried to make it less
attractive for property speculators to
invest in the market
by sort of tweaking the tax laws and
they've
made a few measures to make it a bit
easier for first-time buyers and also to
free up land to build houses on
and what impact may some of these
measures have i mean will we see the
prices come down
yes well i mean it's still early days to
see what kind of impact it's going to
have the jury i suppose we could say the
jury's still out
but as far as people who are renting
houses go
they are critical of it they think that
the tax changes
mean that landlords will just pass on
that extra cost to them
their rents will go up which will make
it even harder for them to save deposits
to get onto the housing ladder
economists are divided as to what sort
of income it will have on
actually cooling the housing market most
think it will have a
limited impact and maybe not for a while
so we might not see any effect for a
while
i think the the main issue that people
are critical of is
that the supply issue hasn't been
addressed enough that
more needs to be done to build these
houses that new zealand needs
all right we'll keep an eye on that
situation that's bloomberg's ainslie
thompson for us in wellington
you've probably seen wind turbines
before with the big propeller-like
blades but now startups in australia and
the uk are making mini-sized ones
helping replace diesel as a power source
joining us for more is georgina mckay in
sydney
georgina tell us more about these small
wind startups what are they doing
exactly
hi sure thank you for having me so
defuse energy
is an australian startup and it was born
when the company's
co-founder and ceo was researching the
use of small wind
to power onboard systems of yachts and
then they made a shift when they
realized the massive potential
of the telecommunications sector that's
forecast to invest some
three billion dollars on distributed
energy assets by 2024
so now defuse has developed a tiny
turbine
about the size of a large standing fan
that's less than three feet wide
and weighs less than a pickup truck tire
that can be attached to the top of a
telecommunications tower
the technology can help replace uh
diesel
as a power source and can be deployed to
isolated locations
like remote mines villages or farms
for now defuse says they're focusing
heavily on the or solely
on the australian telecommunications
market but they've had international
interest
from companies across south africa the
uk
and southeast asia and how does this
tech compare to solar projects that are
also small scale
sure so there is a company
in the uk alpha 311 who has produced a
similar small wind
turbine it looks a little bit different
but this particular technology
is being used to power the o2
entertainment arena which is pretty cool
it's also been designed to work when
cars drive past the turbine spins
and then create generates electricity
these companies producing small wind
technology they're not going to replace
power plants but they are creating
solutions for niche applications like
telcos and remote sites
and they may look small but even these
could cut down our energy bills right
potentially
yes for sure so when technology like
what defuse has created is
integrated into existing technologies
such as solar panels
and battery systems then it can
definitely reduce
costs because it um reduces the need for
diesel
and obviously this has environmental
benefits because diesel
produces a lot of carbon so this small
wind technology
definitely has a place in the global
energy market
all right maybe we'll start seeing more
of these small wind turbines
all right that's georgina makai for us
in sydney
you're watching quick take geo here's
what's coming up after the break
it's tea time in singapore where golf
club memberships are going for a premium
while in the uk migrant workers are
leaving the country at a record pace
access the financial world on demand
hear from leading economists
policymakers
and industry experts via live and
on-demand webinars
only from bloomberg
start exploring to see what's moving the
markets
visit bloomberg.com webinars
our generation's biggest problem climate
change
is happening and the world's most
innovative solutions
transport industry uh buildings
electricity
all of those things everything you need
to know about our changing environment
the politics of global warming we can
and we will deal with climate change
in the fight against climate change
bloomberg green has you covered
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
instead of spending money on travel
singaporeans who are stuck on the island
are investing in golf memberships until
borders reopen memberships at exclusive
clubs have been a solid investment
during the pandemic
soaring to record highs david scanlan
hits the green
in many ways golf is the perfect
pandemic sport
numbers are kept at four you're outdoors
social distancing is easy
it's not surprising that golf is
enjoying a renaissance all around the
world
this is so true in singapore here where
we're finding the
golfers are flocking to golf courses tee
times are almost impossible to get
golf pros are running off their feet
giving classes and prices for the
memberships are skyrocketing
at some of the top clubs every time when
we open up the
the booking system there's always
five times also a
number of golfers trying to book a slot
it's overwhelming it's good for us
business-wise
but it's difficult to to satisfy
all the golfers at the top club sentosa
which is hosting an lpga event later
this month
prices have soared to more than a
quarter million us dollars
since the pandemic struck that's up
about 50 percent from a little over a
year ago so singaporeans are buying
but so are foreigners particularly from
china from hong kong who are looking for
a chance to play golf
but also to get in a good investment if
you go back 20 years
the return on the sentosa membership has
exceeded the stock market here in
singapore
it is on par with the s p 500 with so
much demand for golf
tee times are at a premium well there's
two games here one is the game itself
and the other
seems to be trying to find a booking as
a group of 16 golfers aspiring trying to
get hold of
a tea time it's been a challenge it's so
difficult even members of the top clubs
are having trouble getting tee times so
what are some doing
they're buying a second membership to
increase the odds of getting that
prized tea time on saturday morning
it's also been a boon for golf bros i've
definitely been the busiest i've ever
been
in the last i would say almost 15 years
here in singapore i've picked up a lot
of new clients as well as some old
clients but
we've all kind of gotten to the point
now where we can almost not take on any
more clientele
we've maxed out for the most part as
many hours in the day as you can
physically teach without getting too
burnt out
as the pandemic eases and borders slowly
open
the boom in golf in singapore will
probably taper off as people are able to
go to neighboring malaysia or indonesia
to get their fix in the meantime the
outlook for golf in singapore
has never been brighter
i'm is older mcdonough in london and
you're watching quick take geo
foreign workers are leaving the uk at
the fastest pace since world war ii
putting an even greater strain on an
economy already hit by brexit
pandemic here's why more people
means a larger economy that's just
arithmetic of course
the uk is currently seeing its biggest
decrease in foreign workers since world
war ii
it's thought that london alone has
already lost 700 000 people in the last
year
and although fewer workers could mean
more jobs in the short term
the long-term impact on the economy is
not so good
what economic researchers tend to find
is that
the negative impacts of migration that
is the extent to which they take
jobs or reduce wages for native workers
tend to be
if they're there at all quite small and
short-lived
in the uk for example we've struggled to
find any really
big negative impacts of migrants on the
other hand
the positive impact seemed quite large
migrants do seem
to boost growth to boost productivity
often to boost entrepreneurship and
innovation
although the long-term benefits of
migrant workers are popular with
economists
the idea has been disputed in other
spheres for centuries
in the case i know uh the best occipus
is the and it's a very well-known case
it's a case of the huguenots
french merchants who were protestants
and they were discriminated against by
the french monarchy
with the 14th in the late 17th century
so
quickly enough they faced uh uh
some uh hostility on the part for
instance of
the silk weavers in the in spitalfields
in east london and so there was a huge
debate
um and what i found interesting about
this example and there were there are
many
others is the similarity of the kinds of
arguments that we
still hear today about foreign migrants
who are coming to a country for work
they want to assimilate because their
religion is different
so in the early 18th century that was
said about these sugar notes because
they were not anglican
obviously the same was said for
centuries about the irish they were
catholics
they were culturally different you know
they were coming from the south they
were coming from france
there were dirty cultural sexual
demeanors were suspicious
and uh and they were coming to steal the
jobs
of the local population these ideas
still feature heavily in modern politics
and although some believe workers are
leaving because of the pandemic
others blame the departures on brexit
whether or not this is the case
it's true that not all migrants are
treated the same
while eu nationals leave the country the
uk government has announced its plan to
offer
some hong kong residents british
citizenship the hope is partly that they
increase the numbers of skilled workers
arriving in the country
and as jonathan points out the british
public has become
considerably more positive and less
worried about immigration over the last
few years
so you know that what's really been
interesting about this is the lack of
any political backlash
the hong kong migrants are presented
as idea migrants so obviously these
discourse
[Music]
implicitly is also a way of saying there
are other people
who are not welcome and i think based on
flawed assumptions the idea once again
that
there is such a thing as the average or
the typical
hong kong migrant they're all
middle class they're all they're all
highly skilled they all want to work
in uh in the financial sector or set up
businesses
whereas many of them are artists uh many
of them
are are young and don't don't want to be
to be pigeonholed in this way
but it isn't all doom and gloom history
shows that populations have always
fluctuated
although the people arriving may change
britain's population is unlikely to keep
declining forever
the uk has historically you know been
a relatively open economy in society
and i don't see that changing
joining us now from london is bloomberg
economics editor andrew atkinson
so andrew you wrote that the uk is
currently experiencing
the worst migrant exodus since the
sacrament war how many people are
estimated to have left
um the truth is that no one knows the
the pandemic
has made it very hard to keep track of
long-term migration flows
before the coronavirus the main source
of information was um
a survey which questioned people uh at
airports and other entry points but it
had to be suspended last march
officials are now having to rely on
surveys carried out
remotely by phone and
one of the issues is that they're
probably
under recording the number of migrants
because migrants are less likely to
respond when uh interviewers contact
them asking them to get in touch uh one
of the early estimates
um from jonathan porches of king's
college london suggested that
as many as 1.3 million uh
foreign-born workers had left that's
acknowledged as now as a bit of an
overestimate
uh others have put the number at around
half a million
but that's a but still a very big number
it's about five percent of the total
migrant population
thank you so much for your time my
pleasure
i'm karumi mori in tokyo and you're
watching quick take geo
still ahead from air jordan's the easy
boost
this online marketplace has it all we
meet the sneakerhead founders of another
lane
that's next
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Applause]
[Music]
our generation's biggest problem climate
change
is happening and the world's most
innovative solutions
transport industry buildings electricity
all of those things everything you need
to know about our changing environment
the politics of global warming we can
and we will deal with climate change
in the fight against climate change
bloomberg green has you covered
[Music]
the sneaker resale market is booming
some kicks going for as much as 9 000
one couple made a business out of it
meet the married founders of another
lane an online marketplace for premium
sneakers that's creating a whole
community
of sneaker heads we started a business
in the middle of a pandemic y'all
however sold
a hell of a lot of shoes
and we knew it was going to happen
because we understood that there was a
need for this type of thing because we
needed it also
the sneaker resale market is booming
totaling an estimated 2 billion dollars
in north america alone
as shoe manufacturers focus on driving
sales away from brick and mortar stores
and towards mobile apps and websites
sneaker resellers
are reaping the benefits
[Music]
the name of our business is another lane
we are the premier destination for dope
kicks
so not only do you have a marketplace
you can sell with
no seller fees and then on top of that
you get communication so you can
you know ask someone hey does a shoe fit
small can i get 50
off those types of things encouraging
community also you have a unique url to
your store
you want to be in the background
when i think about sneakers and my
infatuation with them
i don't wear it like a badge of honor
it's kind of embarrassing
and so when i wanted to ask her out i
mentioned it very like
ever so slightly and adina kind of just
shrugged it off like
everybody's into sneakers so you're no
different than anybody else
until the first time i visited his house
i was like oh
this is different his entire bedroom
looks like the back room of foot locker
[Music]
yeah so this is my favorite place in the
world because this is where i house
my personal collection this is a air
jordan 2009
prototype sample inspired by april
holmes
she is a gold medalist uh paralympian
lebron 4 all-star player edition that he
wore in the all-star game
and last jordan brand just came out with
the jordan 11 adapt
this is nike's first auto lacing
air jordan 11. every shoe that adina
likes is either from the 70s or the 80s
me i like the new stuff anything new and
different that's what i want to try out
and i want to be the first to tell you
if it sucks
or if it's awesome
the challenges of being business
partners and be married
especially in a pandemic your home is
your office your office is your home
i was saying some days i'm the janitor
you know and then other days i'm the cfo
chad has seen you know returns of
hundred to a thousand percent
on some shoes the stewie griffin is
actually the highest dollar amount for
one pair of sneakers so the shoe was
never released to the public
about two years ago i sold that shoe for
nine thousand dollars
just to see people old goal at a shoe
that they've
only heard of and to see people's jaws
just drop like isn't that what we do
with art all the time
is we go to a museum we look at it we
love it we talk about it because it
makes us feel things
i mean that's what my personal
collection is it's my museum in my house
the sneaker boom has also created
opportunities for a new generation of
speculator
the potential to get rich quickly in an
informal setting with little oversight
drew a new breed of online gen z trader
exchanges like stockx they commodify
this hobby that we love the personal
communication was taken out
and community was taken away i don't
think that the
audience has changed i think that it has
grown and so it has expanded to include
the white kid from the suburb that is
influenced by
the black culture i'm so happy to see
the world
enjoy sneakers and see what's so dope
about them
but it can sometimes feel like a
gentrification you want it to still have
some of the flavor
the people that made it what it is
that's another reason why
we were so happy to create another lane
is that we didn't see anybody that
looked like
us at the top of these sneaker companies
and so we wanted to
assign that face and put us back into
space and places
in my younger years it was completely
and totally for the
the passion and the art of it i had all
these sneakers because i love them i
love to wear them i love to play in them
i love to show them off
also it's it's really about the personal
connections that you make along the way
there are people that chad waited in
line with with sneakers and
now they're really close friends and
he's been in their wedding
that is what a community gives you
it's expanded my life like i'm from
brooklyn my network though has taken me
all over the world
because of my life for sneakers i know
what it felt like when
i got that pair of shoes from my
personal collection
so to be able to share something like
that and that same feeling
be transferred that's the best part of
it
[Music]
thanks so much for watching this episode
of quick take geo
follow us on twitter at quicktake for
all the latest news from around the
world
till next time
[Music]
access the financial world on demand
hear from leading economists
policymakers
and industry experts via live and
on-demand webinars
only from bloomberg
start exploring to see what's moving the
markets
visit bloomberg.com webinars
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
just imagine living in this 15 million
dollar home
you're paid a steady salary supported by
a whole team of staff whose sole purpose
is to get you to play at your best all
right fellas let's go
and if you don't perform you're cut from
the team
here we go round three round three keep
it going no breaks
if you think this sounds like the life
of a pro athlete
you'd be right kind of
stop you bitchin it's the life of the
sports player of the future
lived by the lucky few today
as technology replaces old jobs it's
also creating new ones
i'm aki ito and i'm here to show you the
jobs of the future
[Music]
my name is michael small i'm a
professional gamer
oh my god for someone who's uneducated
in the esports scene and doesn't
understand how it works
the way i would describe it is it's kind
of similar
to a professional athlete it's a lot of
preparation
hard work and team effort i think one
guy's above me
no trust me he's not ghost gaming pays
players like mike to compete in video
game battles
and yes that is a real job now
more people watch video games than
netflix hulu
espn and hbo put together and esports is
already a billion dollar industry
[Music]
that's how ghosts can afford to shower
players with all kinds of perks
like this team house it's a 10 bed 16
bath mansion
overlooking hollywood and it houses 10
players at a time
all in their late teens and early 20s so
when most people
just take a quick look at the house
we're living in it's a bunch of
teenagers
and it's a lot of us so you would think
it's rowdy we're just reckless but
we're professional esports players
here's the day of a professional gamer
[Music]
i wake up 9 00 9 30.
breakfast chest up chest up let's go
11 a.m we have workouts that lasts for
an hour
to an hour and a half here you go mike
pushing straight in the ground
eight nine and ten
after we do that we hit the film session
and we watch film
on other teams to see what they do just
taking his time make sure you guys take
your time you don't need to be fancy
with it just need to make sure to hit
the shots you need to hit
oh man after lunch we
played from 1 30 to 7 30.
[Music]
i'm not going to be lighter or louder
later probably
one
[Music]
and that's just a long grind of playing
against other talented teams
good job we played from
lunch to dinner you have a wild lobster
with chive butter
i put it on twitter
how you doing mine looks amazing
mike's been playing video games since he
was five
but when his parents got divorced that's
when he really buckled down on gaming
i would just get at my desk turn my game
on
it's like i would disappear and go into
another world and forget about all that
when he was 14 mike qualified in the pro
league of the popular video game call of
duty
he became one of the youngest
professional players in the game
when i first walked into the event i was
just amazed and just fell in love with
it
that's when i knew this is what i wanted
to do
that conversation with his parents
telling them he was pursuing a career as
a professional video gamer
well imagine your kid telling you that
there was a lot of arguments and late
nights
but mike promised to put school first
and his parents eventually came around
well as a single parent it wasn't easy
in my mind i really couldn't foresee it
as a career
but we were at the mall and
some young boy came up to mike and he
said excuse me
are you spacely and mike said yeah
he goes can i have your autograph and i
started to cry
and i'm like this is crazy i'm like he
recognized you mike
and that was instrumental for me as well
realizing
how this has taken off i started earning
money
at these tournaments after my third
local event that was
like one of the best feelings ever being
able to go home and like look my look
dad like today i got paid for playing
i wasn't just wasting my time and i
wasn't just making up like stories and
fairy tales just so i could play video
games more
mike didn't want to discuss his contract
but when he joined ghost
it was reported that he and his
teammates shared a 50 000
signing bonus and we're each offered a
four thousand dollar a month salary
on top of all that mike also earns money
on the side
fans pay to watch and play on the
popular streaming site twitch
and he also sells his own line of
apparel
that all makes for a pretty good living
by the standards of
any 20 year old but it's even better
when you consider that almost
all of his expenses from his rent to his
food to his training
to his gaming related travel is all paid
for
which leaves a lot of room for shopping
can i take them off
yeah all right we got the yeezys mo
rocks i've been a fan of shoes forever
so
there's a lot of times where i spend an
insane amount of money on shoes
but like professional sports gaming is
not a lifelong career
and there's a ton of turnover too three
months after i met mike
ghost dropped him from the team and he's
now back home in new jersey
this sounds very tragic and could nearly
end a player's career but
this is a very common thing in the scene
and players get released and
switched around all the time my advice
to young gamers that want to play
professionally
you got to stay patient you got to stay
dedicated and understand that it's going
to take sacrifice
because there's always another person
out there trying to take that spot
but i don't have any plans to give up
the gaming career
i'm going to bounce back from this and
make my mom and dad proud